ALL RIGHT. WHY DON'T WE GET
STARTED. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
I'D LIKE TO CALL THE BEATING TO
ORDER THIS IS THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICIES- WE WOULD LIKE
TO A HIGH I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL. MORE MEMBERS- THAT
INDICATED THAT THEY WILL BE
ATTENDING AND SO WE'D LIKE TO-
GET STARTED. THANK YOU TO ALL
THAT ARE HERE- TODAY'S AGENDA IS
A OUR ANNUAL UPDATE ON THE
STATEWIDE TRENDS OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AS WELL AS- THE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED OVERVIEW OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO SCOPING
PLAN. WE ARE EXCITED TO I GET A
HOPEFULLY A PREVIEW OF THE
UPCOMING SCOPING PLAN WE
UNDERSTAND THE DRAFT IS
SCHEDULED TO BE RELEASED- AND A
MATTER OF WEEKS- BUT- WE WILL BE
HEARING FIRST FROM THE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. MS LIANE RANDOLPH
FOLLOWED BY THE CHAIR OF THE
INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS MARKET
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. DALLAS RETRO
. I AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST THE A
MEMBER. OF V. ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ADVISORY COMMITTEE OF
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
CATHARINE GROUP- WHITE OF
FOLLOWING THAT I I'D LIKE TO
TAKE UP ALL QUESTIONS OF FOR ALL
THREE SPEAKERS ARE- FOLLOWING
THE PRESENTATION OF ALL. THREE
AND SO WHAT WE LIKE TO GET
STARTED. LET ME FIRST A TURN
OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE A CENTER BACK OR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT JUDY THANK
YOU CHAIR I THANK EVERYONE AT
THE A RESOURCES BOARD FOR THE
PORT WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING
OVERSEEING OUR CLIMATE POLICIES
AND DEVELOPING THE LATEST
SCOPING PLAN- THIS WORK IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND- I'M-
CARP DOES RECEIVE SOME CRITICISM
INCLUDING EXPECT MAYBE SOME
TODAY. FOR NOT GOING FASTER OR
FOR GOING TO FASTER FOR LOTS OF
WAYS. IN WHICH- THINGS COULD
POSSIBLY BE BETTER I'M BUT I
DON'T WANT TO FORGET THAT CARBS
ONE THE MOST EXPERT AND AFFECTED
REGULATORY AGENCIES FOR DRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD. AND WE SHALL BE PROUD OF
WHAT HAS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED. EVEN
IF WE CONTINUE TO PROD-
IMPROVEMENTS ALONG THE WAY.
THAT'S WHEN I THINK OF MEMBERS
OF THE INDEPENDENT MISSIONS MARK
ADVISORY COMMITTEE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ADVISORY COMMITTEE- YOU
PRIDE CRUCIAL INDEPENDENT VIEW
POINTS ABOUT HOW THIS WORK CAN
BE DONE. DIFFERENTLY AND BETTER
AND HELPS US ALL- BY DRIVE
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT PROCESS
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO DIVING THE
FINDINGS OF THE SCOPING PLAN
MODELING SERIES TODAY AND HOPE
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP IN
MAPPING OUT THE PATHWAY OPTIONS
FOR GETTING TO NET ZERO. AND IT
WILL CONTINUE REVISED REFINE
THESE NET ZERO SCENARIOS AS WE
CONSIDER OUR PA POLICY. OPTIONS
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
IMPORTANT WORK. THANK YOU OF I
SHARE WE ALSO HAVE SENATORS-
ALLEN AND STERN- CENTERS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO HAVE ANY OPENING
REMARKS. IS YOUR MIKE ON NINE.
OTHER NIGHT OF THERE AGAIN OKAY
. ALL RIGHT WE COULD GO. OKAY
ALL RIGHT WELCOME J. AROUND OFF.
ALL RIGHT SON YES OKAY ED THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME- AND I
THINK I HAVE SOME SLIDES YES-
THIS ANNUAL HEARING IS ONE OF
THE MANY FORMS OF REPORTING AND
OVERSIGHT FOR CARBS CLIMATE
PROGRAMS AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO UPDATING YOU ON OUR PROGRESS
ON AIR QUALITY AND EMISSIONS
TRENDS. AND IMPORTANTLY ON THE
WORK AHEAD TO ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY AND AVOID THE WORST
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY FOR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THIS
YEAR IS PARTICULARLY NOTABLE AS
WE WILL ADOPT A NEW SCOPING PLAN
UPDATE WHICH WILL EVALUATE OUR
PROGRESS TOWARDS OUR TWENTY
THIRTY GOAL AND CHART A PATH TO
ACHIEVING OUR TWENTY FORTY FIVE
GOAL OF CARBON NEUTRALITY. THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED CARB OVER
FIFTY YEARS AGO WITH THE GOALS
OF ATTAINING AND MAINTAINING AIR
QUITE HEALTHY AIR QUALITY
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC FROM
EXPOSURE TO TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS. PROVIDING
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES FOR
COMPLYING WITH AIR POLLUTION
RULES AND REGULATIONS AND
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX OUR WORK. EXPANDED TO
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. OKAY LET'S LOOK AT
AIR QUALITY THE FEDERAL EPA SETS
HEALTH BASED AIR STANDARDS AND
AS REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW TO
REGULARLY REVIEW THOSE STANDARDS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE HEALTH
PROTECTIVE. OXIDES OF NITROGEN
NITROGEN CALLED KNOX ARE ONE OF
THE KEY SMOG FORMING POLLUTANTS
WE CONTROL TO PREVENT OZONE
FORMATION. KNOX EMISSIONS HAVE
BEEN STEADILY DECREASING SINCE
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES DUE TO
MULTIPLE REGULATIONS ADOPTED
OVER TIME AND THIS CHART SHOWS
THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE IN
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS. THIS
PROGRESS REFLECTS THE BENEFITS
OF BOTH CARB AND EPA PROGRAMS
FOR MOBILE SOURCES LIKE CARS
TRUCKS AND OTHER EQUIPMENT. AS
WELL AS AIR DISTRICT PROGRAMS
FOR STATIONARY SOURCES. BECAUSE
OF THESE MOBILE SOURCES
RESPONSIBLE 480% OF KNOX
EMISSIONS MORE STRINGENT ENGINE
STANDARDS CLEANER FUELS AN
INCENTIVE FUNDING HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR A LARGE PORTION
OF THIS PROGRESS. FOR EXAMPLE
NEW CARS ARE 99% CLEANER THAN A
CAR FROM THE EARLY NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. CALIFORNIA LED THE
NATION WITH OUR ENGINE TESTING
AND CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS AND
CONTINUES TO DO SO AT OUR NEW
LAB IN RIVERSIDE THAT OPENED AT
THE END OF LAST YEAR. AS YOU
KNOW THE STANDARD SET HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE COPIED THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY AND THE WORLD.
THAT'S PEOPLE WELL BEYOND OUR
BORDERS BENEFIT FROM
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN CLEAN
AIR. WE HAVE ENDEAVORED ALONG
WITH THE AIR DISTRICTS TO REDUCE
RISK FROM EXPOSURE TO AIR TOXICS
WHICH COME FROM REFINERIES
SMALLER SOURCES LIKE GAS
STATIONS AND MOBILE SOURCES LIKE
DIESEL TRUCKS. CALIFORNIA'S AIR
TOXICS PROGRAM BEGAN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE WITH THE ADOPTION
OF THE TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT
IDENTIFICATION AND CONTROL ACT.
AND SINCE THEN THE STATE HAS
IDENTIFIED OVER TWO HUNDRED
SUBSTANCES THAT ARE HAZARDOUS TO
HUMAN HEALTH INCLUDING LEAD
BENZENE. TELL YOU MEAN AND AS
BEST AS- TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AND
EXPOSURE TO THESE POLLUTANTS WE
HAVE ADOPTED NUMEROUS
REGULATIONS INCLUDING LIMITING
THE LEVELS OF BENZENE IN
GASOLINE. AND PHASING OUT THE
USAGE OF CARCINOGENS AND DRY
CLEANING BY TWENTY. TWENTY
THREE. TODAY THE STATE'S EFFORTS
CONTINUE TOFOCUS ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS OF DIESEL PARTICULATES
WHICH ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT 70% OF
TOTAL KNOWN CANCER RISK RELATED
TO TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS. FOR
MOST CALIFORNIANS SMOG SO THICK
YOU COULDN'T SEE THE SAN GABRIEL
MOUNTAINS FROM LOS ANGELES IS
NOT JUST IN LIVING MEMORY BUT IN
RECENT MEMORY. NOW THE AIR IS
CLEANER STATEWIDE THIRTY
THOUSAND PREMATURE DEATHS ARE
AVOIDED EACH YEAR TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ASTHMA CASES
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY AND ALL WHILE CALIFORNIA
HAS GROWN TO BE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
BUT WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO DO
MORE. APPROXIMATELY TWO THIRDS
OF CALIFORNIANS THIRTY NINE
POINT FIVE MILLION RESIDENTS
STILL LIVE IN COMMUNITIES THAT
EXCEED FEDERAL HEALTH PROTECTIVE
STANDARDS EXPOSURE TO DIESEL
PARTICULATES IS TOO HIGH
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES NEAR
FREIGHT FACILITY SUCH AS PORTS
RAILYARDS DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
AND THOSE THAT ARE CLOSE TO
FREEWAYS AN INDUSTRIAL SOURCES.
LET'S TURN TO GREENHOUSE GAS
TRENDS THE CHART ON THE LEFT
REPRESENT STATEWIDE ANNUAL GHG
EMISSIONS FROM SOURCES IN THE AB
THIRTY TWO INVENTORY FROM. TWO
THOUSAND TO TWENTY NINETEEN THE
MOST RECENT YEAR WITH PUBLISHED
DATA. SINCE THE PEAK LEVEL IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
CALIFORNIA'S GHG EMISSIONS HAVE
GENERALLY FOLLOWED A DECREASING
TREND. THESE ARE TWENTY NINETEEN
EMISSIONS DUE TO WHEN DATA
ACTUALLY BECOMES AVAILABLE TO
CARB AND OUR NEED TO DO QUALITY
ASSURANCE AND QUALITY CONTROL
CARP HAS NOT PUBLISHED ACTUAL
DATA REFLECTING THE EFFECT OF
THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC THAT TOOK
HOLD IN TWENTY TWENTY. IN TERMS
OF ANY MISSIONS OUTLOOK THE
TWENTY TWENTY GHG EMISSIONS DATA
WILL BE AVAILABLE LATER THIS
YEAR. AND WILL LIKELY BE EVEN
LOWER DUE TO THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. HOWEVER AS ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY REBOUNDED FROM TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT
IS LIKELY THAT GHG EMISSIONS
WILL ALSO FOLLOW THE INCREASED
ACTIVITY. MEANING TWENTY TWENTY
MAYBE SEYMOUR IS AN OUT LIAR
VERSES AS A GENERAL TREND MARKER
. THE EXCHANGE ECOSYSTEM CARBON
BETWEEN THE ATMOSPHERE AND THE
PLANTS AND SOILS IN LAND IS
SEPARATELY QUANTIFIED IN CARDS
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
ECOSYSTEM CARBON INVENTORY.
WHICH IMPORTANTLY INCLUDES
WILDFIRE EMISSIONS. THIS
INVENTORY TRACKS HOW MUCH CARBON
EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA'S ECOSYSTEM
AND WHERE THAT CARBON IS LOCATED
AT DISCRETE MOMENTS IN TIME AND
ESTIMATES HOW MUCH CARBON IS
MOVING IN AND OUT OF THE VARIOUS
PLAN TYPES AND CARBON POOLS. IT
CONSISTS OF FOREST AND OTHER
NATURAL LANDS CROPLANDS URBAN
FORESTS WETLANDS AND SOIL CARBON
. LANCE CAN BE A NET SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS OR IN
THAT SINK. THE GRASS ON THE
RIGHT SHOW TRENDS IN CARBON
STOCK CHANGE OVER TIME. NOTE
THAT IN JUXTAPOSITION TO FOSSIL
FUEL EMISSIONS WHERE THE GOAL IS
TO SEE A DECLINING TREND. FOR
NATURAL WORKING LANDS WE
TYPICALLY WANT TO SEE A STABLE
OR INCREASING TREND IN CARBON
STOCKS WHICH INDICATES INCREASED
CARBON SEQUESTRATION OR ONGOING
CARBON STORAGE AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. SOIL
IS THE LARGEST CARBON RESERVOIR
INCLUDED IN THE INVENTORY.
FOREST AND SHRUBLAND CARBON
STOCKS ARE THE SECOND LARGEST
CARBON POOL AND ALSO CURRENTLY
SUBJECT TO SOME OF THE LARGEST
TOTAL CHANGES. IN TWENTY TEN
CARBON STORED IN FORESTS AND
SHRUBLANDS WAS 6% LOWER THAN IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE DUE TO A
LARGE AND DUE TO A NUMBER OF
LARGE WILDFIRES THAT OCCURRED
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND AND ONE
TO TWO THOUSAND AND TEN PERIOD.
WOODY CROPS AND URBAN FORESTS
BOTH GAINED CARBON AS THESE
TREES ARE GENERALLY WELL
MAINTAINED DUE TO THEIR ECONOMIC
AND AESTHETIC VALUES. PART OF
THE CARBON GAINS SEEN IN URBAN
FOREST ALSO CAME FROM EXPANSION
OF THE URBAN FOOTPRINT OVER THIS
PERIOD OF TIME. AS WE MOVE
TOWARDS CARBON NEUTRALITY
NEUTRALITY WE NEED A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
ANTHROPOGENIC AND NATURAL CARBON
EMISSIONS AND SINKS. AS I'VE
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR REMAINS
THE LARGEST SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE GAS AND
KNOCKS THE MISSIONS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA'S GHG
EMISSIONS WERE FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN MILLION METRIC TONS OF
CARBON DIOXIDE EQUIVALENT.
TRANSPORTATION IS THE LARGEST
ANTHROPOGENIC SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIA GHG EMISSIONS AT 41%
OF THE TOTAL. AND TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS ARE OVER 50% WHEN
ACCOUNTING FOR THE PORTION OF
INDUSTRIAL EMISSIONS RELATED TO
FUEL PRODUCTION AND DELIVERY.
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS
ALSO THE DOMINANT SOURCE OF THE
NITROGEN OXIDES ARE KNOCKS
EMISSIONS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
OZONE AND PARTICULATE AIR
QUALITY PROBLEMS. WITH
APPROXIMATELY 80% COMING FROM
THE SECTOR AS A WHOLE. IN
PARTICULAR THIS IS DOMINATED BY
THE HEAVY TRANSPORTATION SEGMENT
WHICH INCLUDES HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
BUSES FREIGHT EQUIPMENT
LOCOMOTIVES MARINE VESSELS AND
OTHER OFFERED EQUIPMENT
ACCOUNTING FOR OVER 60% OF THE
STATE'S TOTAL KNOCKS EMISSIONS.
IN ADDITION DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER MAKES UP 30% OF ALL
PARTICULAR MATTER EMISSIONS FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
UNLIKE OTHER PARTICULATE MATTER
INCLUDED IN THE PARAGRAPH DIESEL
PM IS NOT A CRITERIA POLLUTANT
BUT RATHER A TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANT. MOVING ON TO THE
SCOPING PLAN UPDATE. THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO SCOPING PLAN WILL
ASSESS PROGRESS TO ACHIEVING OUR
TWENTY THIRTY TARGET. AND WILL
EVALUATE HOW TO PUT OURSELVES ON
A PATH THAT ULTIMATELY ACHIEVES
CARBON NEUTRALITY. ON THIS
GRAPHIC WE'RE SHOWING OUR
HISTORICAL EMISSIONS TRENDS FOR
THE ENERGY AND INDUSTRIAL
SECTORS IN COMPARISON TO BOTH
OUR PREVIOUS TWENTY TWENTY
TARGET AN UPCOMING TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET A 40% BELOW NINETEEN
NINETY LEVELS BY TWENTY THIRTY.
ON THE FAR RIGHT WE ALSO SHOW
THE TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
EXECUTIVE ORDER TOTAL OF 80%
BELOW NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY
TWENTY FIFTY. IF WE ACHIEVE THE
TWENTY THIRTY TARGET AND
MAINTAIN THAT RATE REDUCTIONS WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE 80%
BELOW NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY
TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY THIRTY IS
AN EMISSIONS TARGET BUT IT IS
ALSO A MILESTONE ON THE WAY TO
ACHIEVING CARBON NEUTRALITY. THE
LEVEL OF TRANSFORMATION REQUIRED
TO HIT CARBON NEUTRALITY BY MID
CENTURY MEANS THAT WE SHOULD
PRIORITIZE ACTIONS IN
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WILL NOT
RESULT IN STRANDED ACCESS AFTER
TWENTY THIRTY. AND WE'RE A
LONGER POLICY SIGNAL IS CRITICAL
TO ATTRACT PRIVATE CAPITAL FOR
ACTION AND INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY. SCOPING PLANS ARE IN
OUR ACTIONABLE PLANS TO LAY OUT
A COST EFFECTIVE IN TECHNOLOGY
FEASIBLE PATH TO ENSURE THAT WE
MEET THE STATEWIDE GHG REDUCTION
TARGETS. IT SCOPING PLAN HAS
INCLUDED SWEET OF POLICIES TO
ACHIEVE BROAD MANDATES AND HAS
NEVER RELIED ON ONE APPROACH TO
ACHIEVING EMISSIONS THEY EACH
HAVE A COMBINATION OF INCENTIVES
REGULATIONS AND CARBON PRICING.
THE PLAN IS ECONOMY WIDE AND
SPANS MANY YEARS AS SUCH IT DOES
NOT GO INTO THE DESIGN DETAILS
OF ANY PROGRAM OR REGULATION.
NOR DOES IT SUPPLANT OR CREATE
NEW STATUTES AND REGULATIONS.
THIS IS OUR FOURTH SCOPING PLAN
UPDATE AT A MINIMUM EACH PLAN
LEVERAGES TRADITIONAL AIR
QUALITY POLICIES TO PROVIDE BOTH
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND AIR
POLLUTION EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS.
AND WE ARE REQUIRED TO MINIMIZE
FOR LEAKAGE WHICH IS WHEN THE
PRODUCTION OF GOODS AND JOBS
LEAVES THE STATE. SO IT LOOKS
LIKE WE REDUCE EMISSIONS BUT
THEY WERE MERELY MOVED OUT OF
OUR INVENTORY. FINALLY AB THIRTY
TWO REQUIRES US TO FACILITATE
SUBNATIONAL AND NATIONAL
COLLABORATION AND THAT POLICIES
BE COST EFFECTIVE AND FLEXIBLE
WITH COMPLIANCE. THIS IS
CRITICAL AS CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS 1% OF GLOBAL GHG
EMISSIONS. WE CANNOT SOLVE THIS
GLOBAL ISSUE WITHOUT ACTION FROM
LIKE MINDED PARTNERS WE CANNOT
DO THIS ALONE. FOR GLOBAL
POLLUTANTS SUCH AS GREENHOUSE
GASES A REDUCTION ANYWHERE IS A
BENEFIT EVERYWHERE WHICH THUS
PROVIDES A DIRECT ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT TO THE STATE. OUR GOAL
HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO DEVELOP
SCALABLE AND EXPORTABLE PROGRAMS
THAT OTHER JURISDICTIONS CAN
IMPLEMENT AND USE TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS WITH IN OUR WITHIN
THEIR BORDERS. THIS IS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST
CONTRIBUTIONS TO ADDRESSING THIS
GLOBAL THREAT. AS MENTIONED
DIRECTION ON SCOPING PLAN GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES ARE INFORMED BY
STATE STATUTES AND EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AFTER EACH PLAN IS
ADOPTED CARBON OTHER STATE
AGENCIES START THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING AND UPDATING REGULAR
RELATED PROGRAMS FOR DEVELOPING
NEW PROGRAMS TO ALIGN ANY
OUTCOMES IDENTIFIED IN THE
SKIPPING PLAN. ALIGNING THESE
PROGRAMS RELIES ON MULTIPLE
DIVISIONS ACROSS CARBON OTHER
STATE AGENCIES TAKING ACTIONS ON
THEIR BASED ON THEIR ESTABLISH
ROLES AND AUTHORITY. FOR CARD
THAT MEANS WE BRING FORTH DOZENS
OF REGULATIONS AND PROGRAMS TO
THE BOARD TO APPROVE WHICH WILL
HELP IMPLEMENT THE PLAN. EACH OF
THESE WILL HAVE THEIR OWN PUBLIC
PROCESS AND DETAILED TECHNICAL
ANALYSIS AND THAT MEANS THAT
SOME REGULATIONS CAN TAKE A FEW
YEARS TO DEVELOP THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS BEFORE GOING TO
THE BOARD FOR ADOPTION. AND
FOLLOW THE REST OF THE REQUIRED
REGULATORY STEPS INVOLVED IN
OBTAINING APPROVAL BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW AND FILING
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE. OUR
LAST COPING PLAN ADOPTED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT LAID OUT A
PATH TO ACHIEVE THE TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET. IT INCLUDES
ACTIONS ON EVERY SECTOR OF THE
ECONOMY AND IDENTIFIED THE NEED
FOR CLEAN ENERGY AND TECHNOLOGY
ALTERNATIVE MOBILITY OPTIONS.
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND
SLASHING SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS. IMPORTANTLY IT
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED TO LEVERAGE
OUR EXISTING AIR QUALITY
PROGRAMS TO ACHIEVE OUR GHG
TARGETS. AND CONTINUE TO DRIVE
DOWN HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION IN
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. KEEP
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD AND THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM HAVE DOUBLED IN
STRINGENCY AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS YEAR TO REFLECT THE STEEPER
RATE REDUCTIONS NEEDED TO
ACHIEVE THE TWENTY THIRTY TARGET
. THE HISTORICAL PERFORMANCE OF
THESE PROGRAMS DOES NOT REFLECT
THE IMPACT THESE PROGRAMS WILL
HAVE UNDER THE INCREASED
STRINGENCY ESTABLISHED FOR THIS
DECADE. VARIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS
THE LEGISLATURE AND STATE
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO SEND STEADY AND
UNWAVERING POLICY SIGNALS THAT
WE WANT TO REDUCE GHGS AND
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE. WE ARE
IN THE SECOND DECADE OF TACKLING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE ARE SEEING
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE HAD HOPED
FOR. WE KNOW CLIMATE ACTION CAN
CREATE AND KEEP HIGH ROAD JOBS
AS SUCH AS IN OUR CLEAN TECH
SECTORS. WE'VE SEEN SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT AND INCREASED
INVESTOR INTEREST IN CLEAN
ENERGY AND CLEAN TECHNOLOGY. WE
HAVE AT LEAST TWO REFINERIES
THAT HAVE STATED THEY WILL STOP
PRODUCING CONVENTIONAL DIESEL
AND INSTEAD PRODUCE RENEWABLE
DIESEL. BROUGH DURABLE DIESEL
PRODUCES 30% LESS DIESEL PM
WHICH IS A CANCER CAUSING
POLLUTANTS THAT CONCENTRATES
NEAR FREEWAYS. BENEFITING
HEAVILY BURDENED COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE OFTEN A ADJACENT. IN
THE MOST RECENT QUARTER FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER RENEWABLE DIESEL
MADE UP 225% OF CALIFORNIANS
DIESEL SUPPLY. THE CRITICAL
ISSUE WE HAVE IDENTIFIED OUR
EXTENDED TIMELINES FOR PERMIT
APPROVALS AND RECONFIGURATION OF
THESE FACILITIES TO PRODUCE THIS
LOWER CARBON ENERGY. PERMITTING
ISSUES ARE ALSO KEY FOR CITING
COMPOSTING FACILITIES WHICH ARE
ESSENTIAL TO REDUCING EMISSIONS
FROM ORGANIC WASTE. AS WELL AS
MOVING FORWARD WITH
TRANSITIONING EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BUILDING NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WILL KEEP
JOBS IN THE REGION AND FOSTER
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. ACHIEVING
SUCCESS ON CLIMATE CHANGE MEANS
WE MUST MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY TO
THE GREEN TRANSITION OF EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE BUILD OUT
OF NEW CLEAN ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE MUST
RECOGNIZE THAT EXECUTION OF THE
SCOPING PLAN. RELIES ON A THIRTY
AT THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
THE OVERLAY OF CARBON NEUTRALITY
IN OUR LONG TERM CLIMATE
PLANNING NEEDS WE NEED TO
REDEFINE OUR SCOPE OF SOURCES
AND SINKS IN THAT FRAMEWORK IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO PLAN.
CARBON NEUTRALITY ISACHIEVED
WHEN HE MISSION SOURCES EQUAL
SYNCS. UP UNTIL NOW EVERY
SCOPING PLAN IS FOCUSED ON
REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM FOSSIL
ENERGY AND INDUSTRIAL FOCUS
SOURCES AS REQUIRED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT AS OUR GOALS
HAVE GROWN TO INCLUDE CARBON
NEUTRALITY WE HAVE EXPANDED THE
SCOPE TO INCLUDE ALL SOURCES
WHICH MEANS THE EMISSIONS FROM
THE NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
AND ALL CARBON SINKS. THE CIRCLE
ON THE LEFT REPRESENTS
CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM AB THIRTY TWO
INVENTORY SOURCES WHICH WE CAN
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO RATCHET
DOWN THROUGH AIR QUALITY AND
CLIMATE POLICY. CARBON CAPTURE
AND SEQUESTRATION CAN ALSO BE
APPLIED TO LARGE EMITTERS OF
CARBON DIOXIDE TO THE MEANT TO
MITIGATE EMISSIONS. NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS CAN BE A NET GHG
SOURCE OR SINK AS INDICATED BY
THE PLUS AND MINUS ASIDE. IN THE
STATE SEPARATE NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS INVENTORY WILL
ALLOW US TO TRACK THE GHG
EMISSIONS AND SEEK RESTORATION
ON NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
OVER TIME. AND BEYOND NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS. THERE ARE
TECHNOLOGICAL CARBON DIOXIDE
REMOVAL OPTIONS SUCH AS DIRECT
AIR CAPTURE. COUPLED WITH
PERMANENT UNDERGROUND STORAGE OF
CO TWO THAT CAN REMOVE EMISSIONS
FROM AMBIENT AIR. ONCE WE HAVE A
SENSE OF GHG EMISSION MITIGATION
FROM OUR SOURCES AND THE
POTENTIAL ROLE OF OUR NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS WE CAN BEGIN
TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO COMPENSATE
FOR REMAINING EMISSIONS IN ORDER
TO. ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY.
WE MODEL FOR ENERGY AND
TECHNOLOGY SOURCES IN ORDER TO
EVALUATE DIRECT EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS FOR MOBILE AND
STATIONARY SOURCES THAT MAY BE
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE. EACH OF THE FOUR
ALTERNATIVES EXCEEDS THE TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET OF REDUCING
EMISSIONS 40% BELOW NINETEEN
NINETY LEVELS. ALTERNATIVE ONE
NEARLY PHASES OUT FOSSIL AND
BIOMASS CONFESSION COMPLETELY
TOWARD ACHIEVING CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
. THIS ALTERNATIVE INCLUDES%
AMBITIOUS INNOVATION IN ELECTRIC
TECHNOLOGY AS THE PRIMARY NON
COMBUSTION OF FOSSIL FUEL
ALTERNATIVE. AND IT REQUIRES
EARLY AMBITIOUS RETIREMENT
VEHICLES AND GAS APPLIANCES IN
BUILDINGS TO PHASE OUT
COMBUSTION BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
. ALTERNATIVE TO IMPLEMENT A
FULL SUITE OF TECHNOLOGIES
INCLUDING ENGINEERED CARBON
REMOVAL AT A RAPID PACE TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TOWARDS ACHIEVING
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. AND THE TRANSITION
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS CONTINUES
BEYOND TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
ALTERNATIVE THREE USES A BROAD
PORTFOLIO OF EXISTING AND
EMERGING FOSSIL FUEL
ALTERNATIVES. IT INCLUDES
ACHIEVEMENT OF THE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR SAID EXECUTIVE ORDER
ELIMINATING INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINES THROUGHOUT THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TOWARD ACHIEVING CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
THE LONGER TIME FRAME INCLUDES
END OF LIFE TRANSITION OF
VEHICLES AND GAS APPLIANCES.
ALTERNATIVE FOR IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT DOES NOT REACH THE TWENTY
FIFTY TARGET OF REDUCING
EMISSIONS 80% BELOW NINETEEN
NINETY LEVELS. THIS ALTERNATIVE
HAS THE SLOWEST PACE OF
TRANSITION AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS. WHAT ALL FOUR
ALTERNATIVES DRASTICALLY REDUCE
OUR DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUELS.
GHG EMISSIONS DO REMAIN IN EVERY
ALTERNATIVE. ALTERNATIVE THREE
IS CRAFTED MOVED TO MOST CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH EXISTING
LEGISLATIVE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
POLICIES AND THEREFORE CARDS
STAFF HAS RECOMMENDED
ALTERNATIVE THREE. THE BOARD
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH I ON ALL OF THESE
ALTERNATIVES IN THE DRAFT
SCOPING PLAN. AS IT COMES TO THE
BOARD IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR. THE
MODELING RESULTS SHOW THAT EVEN
AFTER WE TRANSITION TO
ALTERNATIVE FUELS THERE WILL BE
RESIDUAL EMISSIONS IN ALL FOUR
ALTERNATIVES AS I NOTED BEFORE.
THE EMISSIONS ARE PRIMARILY
ASSOCIATED WITH METHANE IN THE
AGRICULTURE SECTOR. COMBUSTION
ENGINE EMISSIONS REMAINING IN
THE ELECTRICITY AND INDUSTRIAL
SECTORS TRANSPORTATION FUELS TO
MEET REMAINING DEMAND FROM
EXISTING. INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINE VEHICLES AND HIGH GLOBAL
WARMING POTENTIAL HYDROFORMED
CARBONS OR HSCS. IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY THESE
RESIDUAL EMISSIONS MUST. BE
COMPENSATED BY CARBON DIOXIDE
REMOVAL FROM THE ATMOSPHERE TO
GET TO ZERO EMISSIONS. TO BE
CLEAR WE ARE MODELING SCENARIOS
THAT FIRST PUSH ON CLEAN FUELS
AND TECHNOLOGY. AND CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL IS TO ADDRESS
RESIDUAL EMISSIONS. THERE ARE
TWO APPROACHES TO CARBON DIOXIDE
REMOVAL NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
AND TECHNOLOGICAL CARBON DIOXIDE
REMOVAL. WE'VE CONDUCTED
DETAILED MODELLING OF OUR
NATURAL THE WORKING LANDS WHICH
I'LL DISCUSS NEXT BUT WE DO FIND
THAT BOTH NATURE BASED AND
TECHNOLOGICAL CARBON DIOXIDE
APPROACHES WILL BE NECESSARY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY NO LATER THAN TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE STATE'S LANDS
FOR A CLIMATE EFFORTS GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
IN OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
DIRECTING CARD TO INCLUDED
TARGET FOR NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS IN SUPPORT OF CARBON
NEUTRALITY AS PART OF THE
SCOPING PLAN. WE HAVE UNDERTAKEN
THE MOST ADVANCED MODELING FOR
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS TO
DATE. THIS IS GROUND BREAKING
WORK AND THE FIRST TIME THIS
LEVEL OF ASSESSMENT OF NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS HAS BEEN
UNDERTAKEN BY ANY GOVERNMENT FOR
IDENTIFYING CARBON TARGETS AND
CLIMATE GOALS. HARDSTAFF
CONDUCTED A META ANALYSIS AND
LITERATURE REVIEW TO CATALOG AND
QUANTIFY. WHAT PREVIOUS RESEARCH
. AS IDENTIFIED AS THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS CARBON. THIS GRAPH SHOWS
THECOMBINED RESULTS FROM CARBS
SKIPPING PLAN MODELING LAID ON
TOP OF THE RESULTS FROM THIS
META ANALYSIS AND ALONGSIDE THE
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
INVENTORY TREND LINE. PREVIOUS
RESEARCH INDICATES A PROBABLE
DECREASE OF CARBON SEQUESTRATION
INTO THE FUTURE. THE CARD
NATURAL THE WORKING MAN'S CARBON
INVENTORY INDICATES WE ARE
CURRENTLY ON THE LOW END OF THAT
TRAJECTORY. CARB SCOPING PLAN
MODELING IS IN LINE WITH
PREVIOUS RESEARCH INDICATING A
POSSIBLE DECREASE IN CARBON
STOCKS GOING INTO THE FUTURE.
EVEN THOUGH NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS MODELING INDICATE
DECREASED CARBON SEQUESTRATION.
IMPORTANTLY THE MODELING ALSO
SHOWS THAT MANAGEMENT CAN
INCREASE CARBON STOCKS FROM THE
BUSINESS AS USUAL TRAJECTORY
REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS FROM LANDS
AND IMPROVE ECOSYSTEM IN PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
UNCERTAINTY EXISTS ABOUT FUTURE
CLIMATE AND THE IMPACTS OF
CHANGING CLIMATE MAY HAVE ON OUR
ECOSYSTEMS IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THE STATE TAKE DECISIVE AND
AGGRESSIVE ACTION. TO IMPROVE
AND DIVERSIFY ECOSYSTEM
STRUCTURES AND MANAGEMENT. THE
MODELING AND COLLABORATIVE WORK
WE HAVE DONE WITH OUR SISTER
AGENCIES HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF INCREASING THE
PACE AND SCALE OF NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS. ACTIONS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR ECOSYSTEMS ARE EQUIPPED
TO WITHSTAND FUTURE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THEY CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT BOTH
NATURE AND SOCIETY DEPEND ON.
FOR SURVIVAL. THERE WILL BE SOME
CHANGES TO THE DATA AND METRICS
FOR THE SCOPING PLAN AS REQUIRED
UNDER AB ONE NINETY SEVEN WE
WILL BE INCLUDING THE COST PER
TON OF MEASURE. THE SOCIAL COST
OF CARBON AN ESTIMATED AIR
QUALITY BENEFITS. IN THIS UPDATE
WE EXPAND ON PRIOR WORK TO
DEVELOP A MORE EXTENSIVE. HEALTH
ANALYSIS INCLUDING MORE
QUANTITATIVE AND QUALITATIVE
ANALYSIS. ONE KEY WAY WE ARE
EXPANDING OUR HEALTH ANALYSIS IS
TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL HEALTH
ENDPOINTS I IMMEDIATE PLANS
INCLUDING EXPANDING OUR HEALTH
AND ENDPOINTS TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL RESPIRATORY AND
DISEASE OUTCOMES. IN ADDITION TO
THE QUANTITATIVE TOOLS THE
QUALITATIVE TOOLS PROVIDE US
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
BEYOND WHAT WE CAN DO WITH THE
QUANTITATIVE ANALYSIS WE CAN
LOOK AT A BROADER RANGE OF
BENEFITS AND IMPACTS ESPECIALLY
ACROSS COMMUNITIES AND GROUPS.
WE WILL USE BOTH THE
QUANTITATIVE AND QUALITATIVE
METHODS TOGETHER TO COVER THE
BROAD RANGE OF BENEFITS. ARE
QUALITATIVE ASSESSMENT CAN LOOK
AT DIRECTIONAL EFFECTS AND THE
SCALE OF IMPACTS AND BENEFITS
AND WILL BE ABLE TO LOOK MORE
CLEARLY AT COMMUNITY
VULNERABILITY AND THE EFFECTS OF
DISPARITIES I'D RE IN RESOURCES
HEALTH CONDITIONS AND OTHER
FACTORS. AND WE CAN LOOK AT HOW
THE GOALS OF THE SCRUBBING PLAN
OUTCOMES WILL IMPROVE HEALTH IN
COMMUNITIES AND ASSIST IN THE
MOVE TOWARD MORE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES. I DO WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THIS IS A STATE WIDE
ANALYSIS THAT WILL INFORM
POTENTIAL COMMUNITY IMPACTS NOT
A COMMUNITY BY COMMUNITY
ANALYSIS. AND LASTLY OF COURSE
WE WILL BE DOING A SEQUEL AND
ALICE'S AS PART OF THIS WORK.
WE'RE PLANNING TO RELEASE THE
DRAFT SCOPING PLAN IN MAY AT
THAT TIME WE WILL RELEASE THE
UNDERLYING MODELING DATA FOR THE
EMISSIONS ECONOMIC AN AIR
QUALITY ANALYSIS. WHICH ARE
UNDERGOING FINAL QUALITY CONTROL
AND QUALITY ASSURANCE CHECKS BY
STAFF. ONE PIECE WE PLAN TO
INCLUDE IS AN UPDATED ESTIMATE
ON THE ROLE OF THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM IN ACHIEVING THE TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET. OUR INITIAL
MODELING THAT IS GOING THROUGH
THAT REVIEW SHOWS IT WILL HAVE A
POTENTIALLY SMALLER ROLE TO PLAY
DUE TO SEVERAL FACTORS- STARTING
AT A LOWER EMISSIONS. FOR THIS
DECADE THAN MODELED FOR THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN.
AS WE COULD NOT HAVE ANTICIPATED
THE PANDEMIC BACK IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. AND THERE'S BEEN KEY
AREAS WHERE WE ULTIMATELY
RECEIVED GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION SUCH AS
THIS AB EXECUTIVE ORDER AND SB
ONE HUNDRED. WHICH CALLED FOR
MORE AGGRESSIVE ACTION ON DAD'S
AND CLEAN ENERGY BEYOND WHAT WE
MODELED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND
WHEN CARP UPDATED THE L. CFS
REGULATION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE CARBON INTENSITY AND WAS
ADOPTED. AT A HIGHER LEVEL THAN
IT WAS MODELED IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SKIPPING PLAN. ON THE
OTHER HAND WE DO KNOW THAT
REDUCTIONS FROM SOME OTHER
POLICIES SUCH AS VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED ARE NOT BEING REALIZED
AS MODELED IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN. AND OF
COURSE THERE ARE UNCERTAINTIES
ABOUT THE RATE OF PERMITTING AND
DEPLOYMENT FOR THE PRODUCTION OF
AND DEPLOYMENT OF CLEAN ENERGY.
THE ROLE OF THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM WOULD BE FURTHER REDUCED
AS ANY NEW TARGETED MEASURES ARE
INTRODUCED OVER THIS DECADE. AS
I MENTIONED AB THIRTY TWO
REQUIRES THAT THE SCRUBBING PLAN
BE UPDATED EVERY FIVE YEARS SO
WE NEED TO BRING THE PLAN BEFORE
THE BOARD FOR ADOPTION BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY TO. THE
TIMELINE HERE DEPICTS THE MAJOR
MILESTONES IN THIS PROCESS. AS I
MENTIONED WILL BE RELEASING THE
DRAFT IN MAY AND IT WILL BE
PRESENTED TO THE BOARD FOR
INITIAL COMMENTS IN JUNE. AFTER
THAT RELEASED THEY'LL CONTINUE
TO BE AMPLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE PUBLIC TO ENGAGE THROUGH
SCOPING PLAN WORKSHOPS ON
SPECIFIC TOPICS. ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MEETINGS AND COMMUNITY MEETINGS
BEING PLANNED FOR THIS SUMMER
AND ON GOING. THROUGH THE FIVE.
AFTER THE CONCLUSION OF THAT
PROCESS WE WILL FOLLOW WITH THE
RELEASE OF THE FINAL SCOPING
PLAN IN FALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
POSTDOCS IN BY THE BOARD AT A
BOARD MEETING BEFORE THE END OF
THE YEAR. THIS LED JUST DETAILS
THE REPORTING AND OVERSIGHT THAT
EXIST FOR CARBS PROGRAMS
INCLUDING OUR ANNUAL UPDATES TO
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS GAS INVENTORY
AND MANDATORY REPORTING. STATUS
UPDATES ON THE SCOPING PLANNING
KEEP CLIMATE PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
REPORTS BY THE IP MAC AND THE L.
A. M. THE FOLLOWING SLIDE
INCLUDES LINKS FOR INFORMATION
FOR CARBON NEUTRALITY THE
SCOPING PLAN AND OUR WORKSHOPS.
BUT OF COURSE THE MOST VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR COLLABORATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT IN
THESE REPORTS BUT RATHER IN OUR
DIRECT INTERACTIONS. I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF MEETING WITH
SOME OF YOU ALREADY TO DISCUSS
OUR WORK AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TOGETHER IN
THE COMING YEARS AS WE STRIVE TO
ACHIEVE OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS. AND REDUCE THE
BURDENS OF AIR POLLUTION ON ALL
CALIFORNIANS BUT ESPECIALLY
THOSE MOST IMPACTED. LAST YEAR
AT HIS PRESENTATION I STATED
THAT BOLD ACTION WAS NEEDED TO
ACHIEVE THE TRANSPORTATION AND
TECHNOLOGY IN THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT AND THE ENERGY
SOURCE IS NEEDED TO ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. AND CONTINUE TO
MODEL TO THE WORLD HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS THIS GLOBAL CRISIS. AS
THE LEGISLATURE CONTINUES THEIR
FORWARD THINKING WE NEED TO
THINK NOT JUST ABOUT OUR
TRANSFORMATIVE VISION AS A STATE
BUT THE NUTS AND BOLTS ABOUT OF
HOW WE TURN THAT VISION INTO
REALITY. WE KNOW WE OF RAN OUT
OF THE LOW HANGING FRUIT AND THE
NEXT TWENTY YEARS OF CLIMATE
POLICY WILL REQUIRE NOT JUST
BOLD VISION. BUT HE
DETERMINATION TO HAVE TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS TAKE A CLOSE LOOK
AT OUR PROCESS SEES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY SERVE STATE GOALS AND
FOCUS ON THE NITTY GRITTY
BUSINESS OF MAKING CHANGE HAPPEN
AT ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT. SO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT TO PRESENT BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
OUR DISCUSSION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A CHAIR AROUND UGH- AREA.
THOROUGH AND INFORMATIVE
PRESENTATION WE REALLY
APPRECIATE TO- ALL THAT YOU
SHARED WITH LIKE TO WORK- TAKE
ALL THREE SPEAKERS BEFORE WE
OPEN UP TO THE COMMITTEE FOR A
QUESTIONS AND SO- CHAIR RAND OFF
WE APPRECIATE TO WE KNOW YOU
HAVE A BUSY SCHEDULE- BUT- WE
WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU COULD-
STAY FOR THE EVENT THAT THE
QUESTIONS. SO I WITHOUT TO ANY
FURTHER ADO I'D LIKE TO INVITE
THE NEXT SPEAKER WHICH IS-
DALLAS PER TRIAL THE CHAIR OF
THE INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS MARKET
ADVISORY COMMITTEE- CHAIR
BIRCHALL. WELCOME.
%
THANK YOU TURN COMMITTEE FOR
HOME INVITING US THE TESTIFIED
TODAY ON BEHALF OF AMERICA
AMERICA'S CREATED UNDER EIGHTY
THREE NINETY EIGHT TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN A OR B. ON THE
PERFORMANCE OF COMPLIANCE
MARKETS FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTIONS I WANT TO
START WITH SOME GOOD NEWS. ON
SATURDAY OF THIS WEEK THE STATE
OF PENNSYLVANIA WILL PUBLISH A
REGULATION OUGHT TO INDICATE ITS
JOINING OF THE REGIONAL
GREENHOUSE GAS INITIATIVE A
COALITION OF ELEVEN LINKED A
STATES IN THE NORTHEAST AND MID
ATLANTIC R. THAT WILL TAKE
EFFECT IN JULY OF THIS YEAR IT
WILL OF VIRTUALLY DOUBLE THE
SIZE OF THE REGIONAL GREENHOUSE
GAS INITIATIVE. AND SO I THINK
THAT IS A POINT DEPARTURE
BECAUSE I'M HERE AS AN ADVOCATE
BUT ALSO A CRITICAL ANALYST
ABOUT THE ROLE OF CARBON MARKETS
AND HOW THEY FIT INTO THE
COMPREHENSIVE. CLIMATE POLICY
PORTFOLIO IN THE STATE. AND
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE OF CARBON MARKETS
SO- SOME OF WHICH ARTICULATED BY
THE BIBLE JUSTICE ADVOCATE.
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND IT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND AND TRY
TO ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS IN
ORDER FOR US TO MAKE PROGRESS.
AT THE SAME TIME I LIKE TO KEEP
IN MIND THAT. OF PUTTING A PRICE
ON POLLUTION CONTRAST SHARPLY
WITH THE CONVENTIONAL WAY THAT
INDUSTRIAL LICENCES TO POLLUTE
WERE ISSUED BY STATES FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE YEARS WHICH
WAS TO GIVE THOSE AND LICENSE TO
POLLUTE AWAY FOR FREE. I PUTTING
A PRICE ON CARBON. LOOTERS HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A COST
TO THE POLLUTION AND DEBATE
GOING TOWARD HER THERE'S AN
INCENTIVE TO TRY TO AVOID THE
POLLUTION EVEN WHEN ALLOWANCES
ARE GIVEN AWAY FOR FREE TO
INDUSTRY THERE REMAINS AN
INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO TRY TO
FIND A WAY TO REDUCE THE
POLLUTION. NOW WE SHOULD REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW MUCH FREE
ALLOCATION THIS CALL FOR AND I'M
GONNA HAVE MORE TO SAY ABOUT
THAT IN A MOMENT. THE THIRD
COMPLIANCE PERIOD JUST FINISHED
IN TWENTY TWENTY. WITH A 100%
COMPLIANCE. THIS SUCCESS
PROVIDES A SOLID PLATFORM. FOR
REFORMS. THAT WERE BEGUN IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. UP FOR THIS
NEW COMPLAINTS BREED AND I THINK
ALSO FURTHER. REFORMS THAT WERE
GOING TO DISCUSS NOW THAT ARE
RECOMMENDED BY I. MAK FOR THE-
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. I DON'T
START BY FRAMING THIS IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE SCOPING PLAN. I
AM. THE ARBY'S BIGGEST FAN. BOTH
INSIDE THE STADIUM WHEN I SPEAK
TO FOLKS OUTSIDE THE STATE AS IT
IS THE LEADING TECHNICAL AGENCY
IN THE WORLD. ON AIR QUALITY AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND- AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTS ALL OVER THE WORLD
LOOK TO THE A. R. B. FOR ITS
TECHNICAL GUIDANCE. AND I'M A
BIG FAN OF THE SCOPING PLAN
PROCESS WHICH IS. REALLY BEGINS
BY IDENTIFYING THE TECHNOLOGICAL
PATHWAYS THE SEED WAY DOWN THE
ROAD ON WHERE WE- NEED TO GO. UP
THE IMAX CONCERNS ARE
INCREASINGLY TO MARRY THAT WITH
A PERFORMANCE ACCORDING TO THE
MILESTONES THAT CHARITABLE.
ENGINE AND THE COMMITTEE ASKED
FOR GREATER CLARITY ABOUT WHAT
THE STATE WILL DO TO HIT THE
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL AND WE WOULD
DESCRIBE THIS IS ALMOST AN
ADDITIONAL SCENARIO TO THE ONES
ARE BEING MODELED. FOR SOME
TYPES OF ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS
ARE MEASURES TAKE EFFECT WHERE
ARE WE WHAT IS THE PROJECT ALL
RIGHT NOW. IN THE COMMITTEE US
FOR GREATER CLARITY ABOUT THE
ROLE OF COPPER TRADING CHORE AND
ALSO THAT WE CAN EXPECT TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THAT. IN THE FUTURE.
ONE OF THE BIG CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CARPENTRY PROGRAM IS THE
ROLE OF THE ALLOWANCE BANK. THE
THERE ARE BEES ARE ASSESSMENT AT
THE ENDOF THE THIRD COMPLIANCE
PERIOD VALIDATED THE
CALCULATIONS BY THE I'M OUT. THE
DOOR OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION.
ALLOWANCES SUPPORT EQUABLE THE
TONS. RESIDING AT PRIVATE
ACCOUNTS EVEN AFTER AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR THE- ON TERRY
ALLOWANCES. AND FURTHERMORE
THERE ARE NEARLY AS MANY
ADDITIONAL ALLOWANCES AND PUBLIC
ACCOUNTS THE COULD REENTER THE
PROGRAM UNDER CERTAIN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. THE PRIVATELY
BANKS ALLOWANCES ALONE OR
GREATER THAN ONE YEAR ANNUAL
ISSUANCE OF NEW ALLOWANCES UNDER
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM THIS
IS A VERY SIZABLE BANK. AND IT'S
GREATER THAN THE PROJECTIVE
CUMULATIVE EMISSION REDUCTIONS
BY SOURCES COVERED BY THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM UNDER THAT
UNDER THE CAP THREE TWENTY
THIRTY. IF THERE'S THOSE
REDUCTIONS ARE CORRECT 4% PER
YEAR. SO THE RESOLUTION OF THE
ALLOW ITS SUPPLY INCLUDING THE
BANK WILL DETERMINE THE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THAT ARE ACHIEVED BY
COVEREDSOURCES. THE MARKET
COVERS ONLY 75% OF TOTAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN THE
STATE. AND IF EMISSION
REDUCTIONS AT THESE SOURCES
COVERED BY THE CAP DON'T KEEP UP
IT'S MEANS THAT WE WILL NOT THIS
NECESSITATED GREATER LEVEL OF
MISTER REDUCTIONS THAT SOURCES
OUTSIDE THE COPS INCLUDING
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS. END
INEVITABLY GREATER REGULATIONS
TO ACHIEVE THE TWENTY THIRTY
GOALS. OF THE COMMITTEE ASKS A
OR B. TO DEVELOP ANNUAL. VISIBLE
ANNUAL METRICS ABOUT THE SIZE OF
THE BANK SO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE PUBLIC CAN OBSERVE THE ROLE
CAP AND TRADE AND TRY TO
CONTRIBUTE CONSTRUCTIVELY TO
SING THE OVERALL GOALS ARE
ACHIEVED IN A COST EFFECTIVE WAY
WE THINK THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM CONTRIBUTES IMPORTANTLY.
TO THAT OUTCOME. SO WITH THIS
LOT LOT SIZEABLE LOANS BANK
BEFORE US THE COMMITTEE HOUSE OF
STUDY POTENTIAL APPROACHES TO
REFORMING THE MARKET THE DEAL
WITH THE EXISTING ALONE SPENT.
WE THINK REDUCING ALLOW SUPPLY
CAN BE ACHIEVED BY THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD USING ITS
AUTHORITY THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
AND THAT IT HAS PREVIOUSLY USED
THE SUB LEVEL THE PRICE FLOOR
AND THE CEILING. IMPORTANTLY
POLICY MEMBERS MIGHT WANT
POLICYMAKERS MIGHT WANT TO
ENSURE THAT REFORMS TO REDUCE
ALLOWED SUPPLY DOES NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
WHICH ENABLE NUMEROUS CLIMATE
RELATED INVESTMENTS OVER HALF OF
THESE ABOUT A INVESTMENTS ACCRUE
TO THE BENEFIT OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND US FOR EXAMPLE
THE DRAFT E. JOCKS SCOPING PLAN
RECOMMENDATIONS POINT OUT. NO
ONE RECOGNIZES THE URGENCY OF
OUR CLIMATE CRISIS MORE THAN
FRONTLINE COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
THOSE VIDAK RECOMMENDATIONS LIST
MANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR EXPANDED
INVESTMENT IN AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES. FOR THE EIMAC
REPORT MAKES SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO ADJUST
THE LEVEL SUPPLY WHILE ALSO
MAINTAINING OR INCREASING
REVENUE TO THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND. AND A KEY IDEA
IS THIS. THAT IF ONLY STATE
OWNED AUCTION ALLOWED SUPPLIES
ARE REDUCED THE REVENUES THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
WOULDN'T EVIDENTLY FALL. TO
AVOID THIS REDUCTION IN REVENUE
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND EACH SOURCE OF SUPPLY THAT
IS ABOUT HALF THE ALLOWANCES
THAT ARE ISSUED FOR FREE TO
UTILITIES AND INDUSTRIAL
ENTITIES AND HALF THAT ARE SOLD
THROUGH THE AUCTION EACH SOURCE
OF ALLOW SUPPLY NEEDS TO BE
REDUCED PROPORTIONALLY. I
BELIEVE THIS CAN BE DONE UNDER A
ABUSE AUTHORITY TO ADJUST
OVERALL LOANS COUNT. THE
COMMITTEE IDENTIFIES TWO WAYS
THAT ALLOW SUPPLY CAN BE REDUCED
ONE IS A SO THE FIRST THAT WOULD
MIGHT OCCUR TO YOU IT'S A IT'S A
DIRECT APPROACH ADDRESS
CUMULATIVE SUPPLY BY REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF ALLOWANCES ARE
ISSUED EACH YEAR GOING FORWARD.
THIS TYPE OF MARKET REFORM HAS
BEEN DONE PREVIOUSLY IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION AND TWICE IN THE
REGIONAL GREENHOUSE GAS
INITIATIVE. TO GOOD EFFECT. A
SECOND APPROACH TO MARK EFORM
WOULD BE TO ADD FURTHER
STRUCTURE TO THE MARKET BY
MAKING THE SUPPLY OF ALLOWANCES
MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE PRICE OF
ALLOWANCES. ONE APPROACH WOULD
BE TO INCREASE THE PRICE FOR.
PERHAPS A BETTER APPROACH WOULD
BE TO ADD ADDITIONAL PRICE STEPS
IN THE ALLOWED SUPPLY FORMULA.
REGGIE DID THIS IT ADDED AN
ADDITIONAL PRICE STEP CALLED THE
EMISSIONS CONTAINERS URBAN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
WASHINGTON STATE INTENDS TO DO
THIS AND DEVELOPING REGULATIONS
FOR THEIR PROGRAM. THIS APPROACH
COULD CHANGE ALLOWED SUPPLY
INCREMENTALLY BY HARVESTING
ADDITIONAL EMISSION REDUCTIONS
ONE ALLOWANCE PRICES ARE LOW.
AND THIS APPROACH DOES NOT HAVE
TO BE DONE EXCLUSIVE OTHER
REFORMS BUT IT IS ONE THAT WOULD
MAKE THE MARKET WORK MORE ROBUST
TO THE KIND OF CHANGES THAT ONE
CANNOT ANTICIPATE GOING FORWARD
BUT WORK FOR WHICH MARKETS
PERFORM SO WELL. WHEN THEY'RE
SET UP PROPERLY. THE COMMITTEE
HAD TWO OTHER COMMENTS ON TO
OTHER INSURANCE. ONE IS OFFSETS
OFFSETS EFFECTIVELY CONTRIBUTE
TO THE ALLOWED SUPPLY BECAUSE
ALSO TO OFFER AN ALTERNATIVE
COMPLIANCE INSTRUMENT THAT IS
ADDITIONAL TO THE CUP. FORCE
CONSTITUTE ABOUT 80% OF ALL OF
OFFICE SUPPLY GOODS CONCERN
CONTINUES ABOUT THE PERMANENCE
OF THIS. MITIGATION MEASURE THE
COMMITTEE IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
REFORMS HERE TO AND ONE OF THEM
THAT IS A COMPELLING IT IS TO
ASSESS EMISSIONS CHANGES THE
STRUCTURE WITH OFFSETS EX POST
AND IT JUST ALLOWED SUPPLY
ACCORDINGLY IF THERE IS OF THE
FAILURE OF THE OFFSETS TO.
ACHIEVE MITIGATION GOALS THIS
WOULD HELP WOULD ADDRESS THE
OVERHANG OF A OF ALLOWANCES-
THAT AND VETERAN SUPPLY AND ALSO
MAY. UP ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
CONTROVERSY OF STRUCTURE WITH
WHETHER OR NOT OF THE FIRST
OFFSET IS ACHIEVING ITS
MITIGATION GOALS. THE OTHER AREA
IS LEAKAGE AND THIS HAS COME UP
ALREADY TODAY REALLOCATION TO
INDUSTRY IS INTENDED TO MINIMIZE
THE LEAKAGE OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
AND ADMISSIONS TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT DO NOT
REGULATE CARBON. RELOCATION
HOUSING OPPORTUNITY COST.
RELOCATION SUBTRACTS FROM OTHER
USES ALLOWED VALUE THE MIGHT. BE
DIRECTED TO TECHNOLOGY.
INFASTRUCTURE AFFORDABILITY OR
INVESTMENTS THOSE ARE DESCRIBED
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THE INFORMATION ON WHICH FREE
ALLOCATION IS BASED IS OUT OF
DATE AND IT SHOULD BE UPDATED
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED THIS
THIS INFORMATION IS UPDATED AND
REEVALUATED. UP WE'VE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF OTHER OF SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT
THAT I KNOW THAT IT'LL BE STAFF
HAVE LOOKED OUT AND WE INVITE
YOUR LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO LOOK
OUT AND WE'D BE VERY PLEASED TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
I WANT TO CONCLUDE BY. MAKING
THIS POINT EVEN RECOMMENDING
CHANGES IS IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER
HOW CHANGES OCCUR MARKETS DO NOT
WORK WELL WHEN THERE'S PERVASIVE
REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY AND AS AN
ADVOCATE OF AN ANALYST FOR THE
CURRENT MARKET WORK IN SWEDEN
ONE MIGHT BE CONCERNED THAT ONE
MARKET SURPRISE TO AN
ADMINISTRATIVE INTERVENTION THE
MARKET. US SUGGESTED ANOTHER
MARKETS PRICE MIGHT BE JUST
AROUND THE CORNER. AND THAT THE
PUBLIC IS REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY
THAT UNDERMINES INNOVATION AND
INVESTMENT AT LEAST AS MOTIVATED
BY THE MARKETS ARE REDUCES THE
INFLUENCE OF THE MARKET WHICH WE
THINK IS THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
CHANNEL AND ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S OVERALL EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS. HENCE WE POINT
TO THE OPPORTUNITY WHERE IT CAN
BE FOUND FOR RULE BASED
ADJUSTMENTS SUCH AS PRICE STEPS
TO CONTROL ALLOW SUPPLY THAT'S
ESPECIALLY ADVANTAGEOUS BECAUSE
THEY TAKE EFFECT AUTOMATICALLY
TO CORRECT THE MARKET AS THE
MARKET MOVES FORWARD. POTENTIAL
POTENTIAL CHANGES SHOULD UNFOLD
WITHIN THE DELIBERATE OF MOLDING
AND REGULATORY PROCESSES WERE
OBSERVING NOW WITH THE SCOPING
PLAN. IN WHICH AND SO THAT THOSE
CHANGES COULD BE IMPLEMENTED A
THOUGHTFUL BUT ALSO TIMELY WAY
SO SPECIFICALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THE SCOPING PLAN CULMINATE.
IN REGULATORY DEVELOPMENT IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
REGULATIONS BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR IN ORDER TO PROVIDE FURTHER
GUIDANCE FOR THE CORPORATE
MARKET. THANK YOU REPORTER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
EACH EVER TRIAL AND- A YES WE
WOULD APPRECIATE IT- IF- YOU
CONDEMN TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
END OF THE PANEL A LAST BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST WE HAVE
DOCTOR CATHERINE GROUP A WHITE A
MEMBER OF THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD'S ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE- DOCTOR GROUP
WHITE WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MURATSUCHI
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS DR
CATHERINE GROUP A WHITE OR
DOCTOR CATHERINE AS EACH TRACK
MEMBERS LIKE TO CALL ME. I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AIR QUALITY
COALITION FOR NEARLY TWENTY
YEARS C. BACK HAS WORKED TO
RESTORE CLEAN AIR TO THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY ACROSS THE EIGHT
COUNTY REGION SPANNING FROM SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY IN THE NORTH TO
KERN COUNTY IN THE SOUTH.
WORKING WITHIN UNSEEDED YOUR
CUTS AND MIWOK LANCE. WE
UNFORTUNATELY ARE THE MOST
POLLUTED AIR BASIN IN THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES FOR FINE PARTICLES
ONE OF THE MOST MOST POLLUTED
FOR OZONE AND AS SUCH OUR REGION
SUFFERS EPIDEMIC LEVELS OF
SICKNESS EVEN PRE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WHICH THE
PANDEMIC HAS ONLY EXACERBATED
ALONG WITH CATASTROPHIC CLIMATE
FUELED WILDFIRES LACK OF ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE AND MANY OTHER
INTERSECTIONAL ISSUES THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES SUFFER WITH. SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT KEEP ME UP AT
NIGHT AND DOING THIS WORK ARE
THE STORIES OF PARENTS HOLDING
THEIR CHILDREN WHILE THEY TURN
BLUE HAVING TO RUSH THEM TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM FOR TREATMENT FOR
BREATHING PROBLEMS. QUESTIONING
IF THEY CAN LET THEIR KIDS
SAFELY PLAY OUTSIDE. STORIES OF
LOVED ONES WHO HAVE DIED TOO
SOON THAT STICK WITH YOU. I AM
INSPIRED BY THE PASSION
INNOVATION CREATIVITY AND WISDOM
OF THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE MOVEMENT
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
BEYOND. AND MAKE NO MISTAKE WE
ARE NOT A MONOLITH SO I'M NOT
HERE TO SPEAK FOR EVERYONE. OR
EVERY SECTOR OF THE EGM MOVEMENT
BUT ONLY OUR PERSPECTIVE. IN
MANY WAYS THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
IS GROUND ZERO FOR CLIMATE
IMPACTS BECAUSE OF OUR AIR
POLLUTION PROBLEMS. HISTORICALLY
WE HAVE SOME OF THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE OIL FIELDS IN THE
UNITED STATES. WHERE THE MOST
AGRICULTURALLY PRODUCTIVE
PRODUCTIVE REGION THAT HAS EVER
EXISTED IN HUMANKIND. NOT TO
MENTION GROWING SPRAWL BEDROOM
COMMUNITIES ON HOUSE FOLKS.
GOODS MOVEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
THESE GIANT SECTORS HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED AND AN OVER RELIANCE
ON MODELS AND PLANS WITH OF
RELIANCE ON INCENTIVES CLEARLY
IS NOT WORKING TO MEET CLEAN AIR
GOALS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
ONE OF THE MANY HATS I WEAR
ALONG WITH BEING THE DIRECTOR OF
C. BACK AND A PARENT IS I'M ALSO
PART TIME FACULTY IN GEOGRAPHY
AND ONE OF MY FAVORITE CLASSES
TO TEACH IS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
GEOGRAPHY BECAUSE I GET TO
CELEBRATE. THE PHYSICAL AND
CULTURAL ABUNDANCE OF OUR STATE
AND HOW IMPRESSIVE WE ARE. WE
ARE TRULY A LAND OF BIG THINGS
WITH THE OLDEST LIVING TREES AND
THE BRISTLECONE PINE THE OLDEST
LIVING PLANT IN THE CREOSOTE
BUSH. THE TALLEST LIVING THINGS
ON EARTH IN THE COAST REDWOODS
THE LARGEST LIVING TREES IN THE
GIANT SEQUOIAS. FROM HOLLYWOOD
HUMBOLDT FROM YOU SOMEBODY TO
THE COLORADO DESERT. WE ALSO
HAVE RICH CULTURAL DIVERSITY THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY BEING HOME TO
THE FARMWORKER MOVEMENT AMONG
MANY OTHER CULTURAL ASPECTS THAT
WE HAVE TO CELEBRATE AND BE
PROUD OF. IT'S ALSO JUXTAPOSED
WITH VOTE THE COST OF. PRODUCING
THE BENEFITS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA HAS SOME
OF THE LARGEST HUMAN ALTERATIONS
TO OUR WATER WAYS. THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IS THE LARGEST
ALTERATION OF THE EARTH'S
SURFACE ATTRIBUTABLE TO
HUMANKIND DUE TO MINING GROUND
WATER FOR AGRICULTURE. SO WHILE
WE ARE THE FIRST FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE ALSO
HAVE SOME OF THE HIGHEST POVERTY
RATES IN THE UNITED STATES. SO
AGAIN THESE BENEFITS ARE COMING
AT A VERY HIGH COST AND THE COST
CLEARLY ARE NOT DISTRIBUTED
EQUALLY. WHILE CALIFORNIA'S
GEOGRAPHY IS WIDELY VARIABLE
CULTURALLY AND PHYSICALLY OUR
ROUTE PROBLEMS REMAIN THE SAME.
RACISM EXPLOITATION AND
EXTRACTION. WE KNOW THE TO MEET
CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE GOALS WE
HAVE TO FOCUS ON DIRECT
REDUCTIONS. THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD'S ORIGINAL CHARGE IS TO
MEET CLEAN AIR GOALS AND WHILE
THEY'RE HAILED AS A LEADER IN
MANY ASPECTS CLEARLY FOR CLEAN
AIR WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO. WE
DO CELEBRATE ACKNOWLEDGE AND
RECOGNIZE THE GLOBAL
SIGNIFICANCE OF CARBS
COMMITMENTS ON CARS AND TRUCKS
AND THEIR IMPRESSIVE HIGH
COMPLIANCE RATES THAT AND
ENFORCEMENT REPORTS SHOW. AT THE
SAME TIME WE HAVE TO PLACE THOSE
NEXT TWO BROKEN PROCESSES WITH
OUR AREA AGENCIES THAT RESULT IN
A MISUSE OF MONEY AND POWER
THERE ARE NUMEROUS LAWSUITS
REGARDING FIELD PLANTS THAT I
COULD POINT TO BUT INSTEAD I
WANT TO USE TO SPECIFIC EXAMPLES
OF PROCESSES THAT I PARTICIPATE
IN. THAT I THINK EXHIBIT OUR
OVER RELIANCE ON TECHNOLOGY AND
INCENTIVES THAT CONTINUED TO
WIDEN AND DEEPEN DISPARITIES AND
IMPACTS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES. SO FOR ONE
I SERVE ON THE STOCKTON STEERING
COMMITTEE FOR THE COMMUNITY-
PROTECTION PROGRAMMER AB SIX ONE
SEVEN WHICH I BELIEVE TO BE A
VISIONARY AND COMMUNITY ENGAGED
PARTICIPATORY PROCESS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE EXPERIENCE.
AS MANAGED BY THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR DISTRICT AS AN
ONGOING DEBATE OVER HOW TO
INVEST DOLLARS AN EQUITABLE WAYS
WITH FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
PUNITIVELY REMOVED FROM THE
COMMUNITIES BUDGET. BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T VOTE FOR MEASURES THAT
THE AIR DISTRICT WANTED THAT
WOULD HAVE GONE TO ONE OF THE
LARGEST SOURCES OF POLLUTION IN
THE AREA OUT WITHOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY OR OVERSIGHT
MECHANISMS THAT WERE REQUESTED
BY THE COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEE. THAT SETS A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITY MEMBERS
SPEAKING THEIR PRIORITIES AND
BEING PUNISHED FOR IT. I ALSO
FOR MANY YEARS HAVE WORK IN
WORKS TO REPAIR THE BROKEN
EMISSION REDUCTION CREDIT
PROGRAM MANAGED BY THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY OR DISTRICT WHICH
IN SOME WAYS IS A PARALLEL TO
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM FOR
CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS. THE
FAILURES OF THE SYSTEM
DEMONSTRATE DEEP CORRUPTION IN
OFFSETTING SYSTEMS AND NOT
COINCIDENTLY HAS FAVORED THE OIL
INDUSTRY AND DESPITE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD U. S. EPA AND
THE AIR DISTRICT AGREEING THAT
THE PROGRAM HAS FAILED. THERE IS
NO PLAN TO RECONCILE THE KNOWN
DAMAGE TO ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES CAUSED BY THE
FAILURES OF THE BANK ONLY TO
MAKE FORWARD FACING CHANGES TO
THE PROGRAM. SO IN THESE
EXAMPLES WE SEE THAT CARBS
OVERSIGHT ROLE OVER OUR AIR
DISTRICTS WHO CONTROL IMPORTANT
STATIONARY AND AREA WIDE SOURCES
IS FAILING. AND THAT WE NEED TO
DO MORE TO ENSURE THAT AIR
DISTRICTS ARE ADOPTING AND
ENFORCING THE BEST RULES AND
POLICIES FOR CLEAN AIR AND
CLIMATE GOALS. SO SEGUEING TO
DISCUSSING THE SCOPING PLAN
PROCESS AND MY PARTICIPATION AS
AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE-
COMMITTEE MEMBER IT ABSOLUTELY
HAS BEEN HURRIED AND RUSHED- WE
RECOGNIZE THAT CARP STAFF ARE
CONTINUALLY WORKING ON THEIR
REGULATORY PROGRAMS AND THIS
PLAN COMES UP TO BE. UPDATED
EVERY FIVE YEARS- THE PROCESS
HAS BEEN OVERWHELMING AND
FRANKLY HAS MOVED SO QUICKLY
THAT IT HAS CAUGHT OUT MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO HAVE
SUBSTANTIVE INPUT FROM FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES. AND EXHIBITS AN
UNDERLYING DYNAMIC THAT
CONTINUES TO DISADVANTAGED
GROUPS WITH LESS RESOURCES.
AGAIN IT'S JUST ONE SPECIFIC
EXAMPLE WITHIN A COUPLE OF WEEKS
OF BEING APPOINTED TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. ALMOST AN ENTIRE WEEK
OF SEVERAL BACK TO BACK DAYS OF
MULTI OUR WORKSHOPS WERE
SCHEDULED AND INITIALLY WITH NO
BREAKS UNTIL WE REQUESTED THEM.
SINCE JUNE WE'VE HAD FIFTEEN
MEETINGS OF VIDAK OFFICIAL
MEETINGS THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
PREP AND DEBRIEF WORKGROUPS OR
WORKSHOPS- AND MANY OF US ARE AS
YOU ALL ARE SERVING IN MANY
OTHER ROLES SO I KNOW WE'RE ALL
BUSY I WON'T BELABOR THE POINT
BUT WE HAVE RAISED MANY TIMES
CONCERNS. ABOUT THE ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN THE TIMELINE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIVE FEEDBACK IN ORDER TO
SHAPE THE MODELING. MODELING IS
A FUNDAMENTAL AND UNDERLYING
ASPECT OF WHAT GOES INTO THE
SCOPING PLAN AND MODELS ARE
TOOLS THAT ARE USED AS A MEANS
TO AN END. IF YOU PUT FAULTY
ASSUMPTIONS INTO A MODEL YOU'RE
GOING TO GET BAD INPUT OUTPUTS
AT THE END. STAFF HAVE NOT FULLY
RELEASED THEIR UNDERLYING
ASSUMPTIONS WHICH INHIBITS OUR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIVE FEEDBACK AT THIS
STAGE IN THE PROCESS. AND NOW WE
HAVE SCENARIOS RELEASED AND
ALREADY STAFF RECOMMENDING A
SCENARIO BEFORE WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO FULLY ANALYZE EVEN WHAT'S
BEEN MODELED. THERE ARE ALSO
TROUBLING ASSUMPTIONS IN THE
MODELING AS IT EXISTS RIGHT NOW-
PRETTY MUCH FROM THE BEGINNING
OF THIS PROCESS ALMOST EVERY
WORKSHOP CARB STAFF HAVE STATED
THAT ENGINEERED CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE IS GOING TO BE
REQUIRED. THIS MODELING NOW HAS
UNREALISTIC ASSUMPTIONS SUCH AS
A 90% CAPTURE RATE FOR
ENGINEERED CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE WHICH IS NOT REALISTIC
AND HAS NOT BEEN PROVEN
ANYWHERE- AND FURTHERMORE WE ARE
UNDERESTIMATING THE POTENTIAL
FOR NORTH NATURAL SOURCES OF
CARBON SEQUESTRATION WHICH AGAIN
IS WHERE WE SHOULD FOCUS.
FUNDAMENTALLY WE'RE NOT ON TRACK
FOR TWENTY THIRTY GOALS AND
MODELS ARE THEORY SO WE NEED THE
ACTUAL APPLICATION TO FOLLOW
THROUGH. NOT ALL SOLUTIONS CAN
BE TECHNOLOGY BASED SO IN THE
WORK THAT WE DO IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY MANY PEOPLE HAVE
SUGGESTED TO ME MAYBE WE COULD
JUST GET GIANT FANS AND BLOW THE
AIR POLLUTION TO SOMEWHERE ELSE
BUT- FUNDAMENTALLY THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE WANT TO DO AT THE END OF
THE DAY RIGHT. AND NOW IN THE
VALLEY WE HAVE MULTIPLE PROPOSED
PROJECTS TO ESSENTIALLY TAKE
GIANT TUBES AND PIPES AND LOCK
CARBON UNDERGROUND FOREVER WITH
LITTLE TO NO CONSEQUENCES AND I
WISH THAT THAT MAGICAL THINKING
WAS POSSIBLE. BUT AGAIN WE HAVE
TO BE REALISTIC AND MOVE FROM
ASPIRATIONS TO ACTIONS THAT ARE
EQUITY CENTERED. BECAUSE HOW WE
ACHIEVE OUR GOALS IS AS
IMPORTANT AS ACHIEVING OUR
GOALS. I DO HAVE HOPE IN THE
WORK THAT WE DO IN EACH RACK AND
I WAS THE CENTRAL VALLEY AIR
QUALITY COALITION. THAT WE CAN
CO POWER WITH PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS AND WITH FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
IN ZERO CARBON INFRASTRUCTURE
AND EQUITABLE PUBLIC SERVICES.
THAT SUPPORT COMMUNITY WELLBEING
AND SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT. I
WANT TO EXPRESS GREAT
APPRECIATION FOR ALL OF THE
PARTNERS THAT HAVE HELPED
DEVELOP THE ROBUST
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED TO YOU ALL. IT'S BEEN
A GREAT COLLECTIVE EFFORT FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO COME UP WITH THE
TWENTY EIGHT. PAGES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THUS FAR THAT
AGAIN IT'S JUST AT THIS POINT IN
THE PROCESS BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
HAD A CHANCE TO WEIGH IN ON. THE
ACTUAL SCENARIOS THEMSELVES OR
THE ADDITIONAL- HEALTH AN AIR
POLLUTION MODELING BUT STILL ON
GOING. SO IT WAS A MADE YOUR
EFFORT TO PUT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS TOGETHER
THERE'VE ALSO BEEN COMMUNITY
COALITIONS WORKING TO INFORM THE
PROCESS. SUCH AS THE BUILDING
ENERGY EQUITY AND POWER OR BEEP
COALITION WHICH HAS HELD
COMMUNITY WAS LISTENING SESSIONS
ABOUT BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH A FOCUS ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES. AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WORKSHOP
THE FIRST AND ONLY ONE THAT'S
HAPPENED THUS FAR OFFICIALLY
FROM THE JACK ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
SECOND. THAT C. ABOUT
COORDINATED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND HAD OVER A
HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS. FROM
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN OUR FRONT
LINE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES. AND THE OVER
ARCHING QUESTION THAT WE ASK
THEM WAS. WHAT WOULD YOU TELL
THE GOVERNOR AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENT THAT YOU WANT IN THE
SCOPING PLAN AND THAT YOU WANT
FROM CLIMATE JUSTICE. I
SUBMITTED VIA EMAIL AND
ATTACHMENT OF A- VISUAL SKETCH
FROM A SKETCH ARTIST IT'S CALLED
A MENTAL MAP. THAT REALLY
SUMMARIZES AND HIGHLIGHTS SOME
OF THE KEY THEMES OF WHAT WE
WERE HEARING FROM COMMUNITY
MEMBERS IN THESE SESSIONS. AND
AGAIN WE HEAR- OPTIMISM AND
EXCITEMENT FOR INVESTMENTS THAT
CAN BE TAILORED ACROSS
TRANSPORTATION BUILDINGS FOOD
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT FACTORS
THAT AFFECT PEOPLE'S DAILY
LIVES. JUXTAPOSED WITH A FEAR OF
CONTINUING TO BE LEFT BEHIND BY
THESE INVESTMENTS THAT ARE MADE
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T LOOK
LIKE OUR FRONTLINE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES. OFTENTIMES
WHEN WE RAISE THESE BIG AND BOLD
VISIONS AS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE MOVEMENT WE HEAR FROM
AGENCIES LIKE THE CARROT
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
THAT'S NOT OUR AUTHORITY OR WE
CAN'T DO THAT RIGHT NOW. THE
SCOPING PLAN IS AN IMPORTANT
EXERCISE THAT SENDS MARKET AND
POLICY SIGNALS RELATED TO KEY
TECHNOLOGY CHOICES AND WE WANT
THE RIGHT INVESTMENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND RECOGNITION.
THAT MONEY AND TECHNOLOGY WILL
NOT SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM. THE
SCOPING PLAN PROVIDES STATE
DIRECTION ON HOW TO MEET CLIMATE
GOALS AND AN ACTIONABLE VISION
THAT MUST INCORPORATE EQUITY
RESILIENCE AND JUSTICE. WHILE I
KNOW THAT YOU JACK
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE LENGTHY I
WOULD PARTICULARLY POINT YOU TO
THE LAST COUPLE OF PAGES WHERE
THERE'S A CHART PUT TOGETHER BY
GROUPS OF SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON ACTIONABLE
MEASURES FOR US TO MEET OUR
GOALS. TRULY THERE NEEDS TO BE
COORDINATION ACROSS THE
DIVISIONS OF THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND ACROSS THE STATE
AGENCIES THAT ALL HAVE A STAKE
IN THE OUTCOMES OF THE SCOPING
PLAN. SO I CERTAINLY CAN'T DO
JUSTICE TO ALL TWENTY EIGHT
PAGES OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
THERE ARE A FEW THAT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FROM SOME OF THE- MOST
IMPORTANT SECTORS. WHEN YOU SEND
TRANSPORTATION AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED AS AND MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND WE KNOW OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED BETTER
CONNECTIVITY MOBILITY AND MATT
MASS TRANSIT. AND TO CONTINUE
THE AMBITIOUS COMMITMENTS TO
ELECTRIFICATION WE NEED MORE
INVESTMENTS AND RAPID BUSES
LIGHT RAIL ANTI DISPLACEMENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WALKING
BIKING TO MEET OUR AMBITIOUS
GOALS AND ACHIEVE REDUCTIONS. AS
I ALLUDED TO IN MY INTRODUCTION
INTRODUCTION INTO INDUSTRIALIZED
AGRICULTURE MUST ALSO TRANSITION
TO AGROECOLOGICAL PRACTICES WE
MUST PHASE OUT DAIRY BIO GAS AND
PETRO CHEMICAL BASED PESTICIDES
WE NEED AT LEAST A 50% REDUCTION
IN PESTICIDE USE BY TWENTY
THIRTY. WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
FOREST HEALTH WHICH I'M BY NO
MEANS AND AN EXPERT IN BUT
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE AND VAST.
ATION OF ECOSYSTEMS BUT AGAIN WE
NEED TO BE TAILORING SOLUTIONS
DEPENDING ON THE LOCAL
ECOSYSTEMS AND COMMUNITIES WE
NEED TO EMBRACE TRADITIONAL
ECONOMIC ECOLOGICAL KNOWLEDGE
AND INDIGENOUS PRACTICES WHICH
WAS SOMETHING THA WE HEARD A
LOT IN OUR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
WORKSHOP. AND REALLY AN INTEREST
IN RESTORING ECOSYSTEMS ACROSS
RURAL URBAN AND SUBURBAN AREAS
WITH PRIORITY FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES THAT COULD
BENEFIT IN MULTIPLE WAYS FROM
FROM THINGS LIKE INCREASED. TREE
CANOPY. FUNDAMENTALLY THE STATE
ALSO NEEDS TO CREATE A PLAN FOR
HOW WE WILL PHASE OUT FOSSIL
FUELS IT'S VERY POPULAR RHETORIC
NOW TO SAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
PHASE OUT FOSSIL FUELS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT HOW WILL WE
ACTUALLY DO THAT. WE NEED
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS IN CLEAN
ENERGY AND NO RELIANCE ON
CLIMATE DEADLINES LIKE CAR
ENGINEERED CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
UNPROVEN IT'S RISKY. AND IT'S
BEEN STATED. BY CARB STAFF THAT
ESSENTIALLY TO BE COST EFFECTIVE
THAT THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS ARE
GOING TO BE CONCENTRATED IN
FRONT LINE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES ON EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE IT MOST
COST EFFECTIVE. I WAS STRUCK
LAST MONTH LISTENING TO THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING AND HEARING
THE E. THREE MODELLER WHO SPOKE
STATING THAT WE COULD IN FACT
MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS WITHOUT
ENGINEERED CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE THOUGH CERTAINLY THE
CHALLENGE WILL BE DIFFICULT. AND
I WENT BACK AND READ THROUGH HER
TESTIMONY AS I WAS PREPARING FOR
THE HEARING TODAY. AND NOTED
THAT HER CONCLUDING COMMENT IN
HER WRITTEN SUMMARIES SAID THE
PRIMARY CHALLENGE THAT I SEE IS
NOT A LACK OF AMBITION BUT A
QUESTION OF HOW WE WILL FINANCE
THESE NEEDED INVESTMENTS. AND
RAPIDLY DEPLOY IN ADOPTING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES IN EVERY SECTOR IN
A WAY THAT IS EQUITABLE. IN THE
CATEGORY OF FALSE SOLUTIONS WE
ABSOLUTELY ALSO HAVE TO TOUCH ON
CAP AND TRADE WHICH I WON'T GO
INTO AT LENGTH SINCE OUR LAST
WEEK- LAID OUT SOME OF THE
ISSUES. THAT THEY'RE COMMITTEE
HAVE- OVERALL IT'S A PROGRAM
THAT CONTINUES TO CONCENTRATE
POLLUTION IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR BY DESIGN. HOW E. PA SEPT
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD COMMITTED
IN A JUNE EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY LETTER FOR A ROBUST
EXAMINATION OF THE PROGRAM AND
TO ADDRESS OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
IT MUST BE ANALYZED FOR ITS
OVERALL ROLE AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT PAGES
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY OF THE E.
JACK RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR VERY
SPECIFIC LIST OF THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ANALYSIS AND REFORMS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE. SO AS
I WRAP UP I DO ALSO WANT TO LIFT
UP THE COMMITMENT TO MAKE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE A PERMANENT BODY AT
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD. HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE THREE EIGHT FIVE
NINE ONE EIGHT SAYS THE STATE
BOARD BY JULY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN SHALL CONVENE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. TO ADVISE IT IN
DEVELOPING THE SCOPING PLAN
PURSUANT TO SECTION THREE EIGHT
FIVE SIX ONE. AND ANY OTHER
PERTINENT MATTER IN IMPLEMENTING
THIS DIVISION CERTAINLY THERE IS
MUCH MORE WORK THAT HAS TO BE
DONE TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS
IT IS AN ONGOING TASK. AN E.
JACK NEEDS TO BE MADE A
PERMANENT BODY WITH ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO WORK AND
CO POWER SOLUTIONS. WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES TO TRULY ENGAGE IN
CO DESIGNED. TO INFORM THE LONG
TERM INTEGRATION OF EQUITY
ACROSS CARDS PROGRAMS LIKE AB
SIX ONE SEVEN LIKE STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS ALONG WITH
THE SCOPING PLAN. TO INFORM THE
DEVELOPMENT AND TRACKING OF
HEALTH METRICS. TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL GROUNDS TRUE THING OF
THE THEORY AND MODELS BY.
BRINGING IN THE INFORMATION FROM
IMPACTED COMMUNITY MMBERS AND
INFORMING HOW PROGRAMS CAN BE
TAILORED. WE MUST MOVE THE
PROCESS TOWARDS CONSULTATION
COLLABORATION AND ULTIMATELY
WHAT YOU JACK STARTED THIS
PROCESS WITH WHICH WAS A REQUEST
FOR CO DESIGN. E. JACK HAS
PROVIDED SUBSTANTIVE FEEDBACK IN
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND WE WANT
THEM TO BE MEANINGFULLY
INTEGRATED. SO LEGISLATORS IN
YOUR OVERSIGHT ROLE I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DIRECT CARD
CARD TO COMPLETE THE BUSINESS AS
USUAL MARC MODELING FOR EXISTING
POLICIES. TO RELEASE ALL OF
THEIR MODELING ASSUMPTIONS AND
DATA. TO CONDUCT A FULL PROGRAM
REVIEW OF CAP AND TRADE AND TO
ENFORCE EXISTING RULES AND
POLICIES SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND. WHY AND WHERE WE'RE
NOT ON TRACK AND WHERE
ADJUSTMENTS NEED TO BE MADE. AND
WITHIN YOUR OWN AUTHORITY I
WOULD URGE YOU TO INCREASE
COMMUNITY POWER TO INFORM
DECISION MAKING ON INVESTMENTS
THROUGH PROGRAMS LIKE EIGHTY SIX
ONE SEVEN AND IN THE STATE
BUDGET. I URGE A RECOGNITION
THAT EXISTING LAWS ARE
INADEQUATE AND WE MUST ADDRESS
CUMULATIVE AND DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACTS. AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU ALL TO PASS BILLS THAT HELP
US PLAN FOR A JUST TRANSITION
OFF OF FOSSIL BASED EXTRACTIVE
ECONOMY THAT TRULY ADDRESSES
DEVELOPMENT OIL AND AGRICULTURE
. OUR BOLD VISION MUST BE MET
WITH BOLD ACTIONS CALIFORNIA IT
NEEDS REAL ZERO NOT NOT ZERO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET ME OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. BY SHARE
BACKER. THANK YOU AT. I
APPRECIATE ALL THE PRESENTATIONS
FROM WONDERFUL AND REPORTER
DISCUSSION- THE INITIAL DATA
SUGGEST THAT. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IS. SLIGHTLY HIGHER THAN TWENTY
TWENTY OF COURSE WITH A PANDEMIC
YOUR TERMS OF TOTAL EMISSIONS
YEAH AND- BUT THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS ONLY ABOUT 2% LOWER THAN
TWENTY NINETEEN IN SPITE OF THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC SLOWDOWNS. SO
WE'RE CERTAINLY GOING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION AT LEAST NOT
FAST ENOUGH AND IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND- BEFORE TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU AND HAD A WEEK
EVERY CHANGE THAT TRAJECTORY.
ONE QUESTION I HAD IS- IS ARE
VERY AMBITIOUS ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
CARBON CAPTURE IN THIS DOCUMENT
I'M SURE MADE RICHER RAN OFF
WHAT OTHER POLICY ACTIONS WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO HIT THE 203540%
REDUCTION TARGET. IF THE
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT CARBON CAPTURE
WERE NOT SO OPTIMISTIC- YOU KNOW
HOW MUCH FOR THE REDUCTIONS IN
TRANSPORTATION OR BUILDINGS
WOULD HAVE TO BE DONE. M. I
GUESS I I'LL HIGHLIGHT A FEW
THINGS I MEAN FIRST OF ALL I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT AND WE
NEED TO TRANSFORM. MANY SECTORS
OF OUR ECONOMY. WE NEED TO
TRANSFORM TRANSPORTATION TO BE
NEARLY COMPLETELY FREE OF
PETROLEUM AS CALLED FOR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
WITHOUT MAKING SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS ON THAT SECTOR- WE WILL
NOT STAY ON TRACK SO THAT WE
NEED TO DOUBLE DOWN OUR WORK
THERE- WE ALSO KNOW THAT- YOU
KNOW THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
WE'RE ON TRACK ASSUMES. KIND OF
A LINEAR PROGRESS YEAR TO YEAR-
AND WE KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAPPEN. WE
KNOW EMISSIONS WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER- IN TWENTY
TWENTY DUE TO THE PANDEMIC AND
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A
BOUNCE BACK BUT WE HAVEN'T
QUANTIFIED THE NUMBERS FOR
EITHER OF THOSE YEARS- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE PROVIDED SOME. ESTIMATES
BUT WE'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR THAT
THOSE ESTIMATES ARE NOT THE
ACTUAL NUMBERS AND- AND ARE NOT
MEANT TO BE USED TO KIND OF SET
POLICY GOING FORWARD RECOGNIZING
THAT THEY'RE NOT THE ACTUAL
NUMBERS SO I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. I'M AND- AND
WITH AS I MENTIONED IN MY PRISON
TATIAN THERE ARE UNCERTAINTIES
WITH ALL OF OUR STRATEGIES FOR
INSTANCE REDUCING VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED IS A CRITICAL STRATEGY-
AND YOU KNOW I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT. A LOT OF WHAT DOCTOR
GROUP WHITE SAID ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRANSIT THE
IMPORTANCE OF- ALTERNATIVE WAYS
FOR GETTING AROUND THE
IMPORTANCE OF. HOUSING A YOU
KNOW HAVING A SUFFICIENT SUPPLY
OF HOUSING IN THE STATE BUT
HAVING THAT HOUSING LOCATED IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS WORKERS TO GET
TO WORK WITHOUT HAVING TO- SPEND
A LOT OF TIME ON THE ROAD. I'M
ALL OF THOSE LAND USE DECISIONS
DECISIONS ABOUT- MAKING
COMMUNITIES MORE SUSTAINABLE ALL
HAVING MORE ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF
JEFF TRANSPORTATION THOSE ARE
ALL CRITICAL POLICY GOALS THAT
WILL GET US WHERE WE NEED TO GO
AND IT'S AREAS WHERE WE KNOW
WE'RE BEHIND. RIGHT SO IT'S NOT
JUST THINKING ABOUT- YOU KNOW
THE TECHNOLOGY PIECES IT'S
THINKING OF ALL OF THE
STRATEGIES IN THE SCOPING PLAN
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE MAKE
PROGRESS ON ALL OF THE
STRATEGIES. SO THE SHORT ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION I THINK IS IF
WE SEE ANY OF OUR STRATEGIES
FOLLOWING BEHIND WE NEED TO
EXPLORE THEM UNDERSTAND WAYS WE
CAN MAKE THEM MORE ROBUST AND
STRONGER. AND ALSO LOOK AT
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEAN INTO OTHER
STRATEGIES TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS ON ALL OF
OUR GOALS. I'M ANY SOME
ADVOCATES HAVE HAVE ARGUED THAT
IS HERE FOR YOU OAK AWAY SAID
SCENARIO- AND I WOULD AGREE.
THAT THE WHAT ABOUT US IN THE
CLOSER TO SCENARIO ONE IN TERMS
OF AGGRESSIVE EARLY. ACTIONS TO
START THE TRANSITION WHILE
GIVING IT A LONGER RUNWAY. SAY
TO TWENTY FORTY FIVE TO GET TO
NET ZERO ME THAT WOULD REFLECT I
THINK IT'S AN AREA BETWEEN.
MAYBE SCENARIO ONE AND SCENARIO
THREE WHICH BELIES. REALLY
HEAVILY ON ON CARBON REMOVAL. SO
AM I THINK AS- I'LL SAY A COUPLE
THINGS I MEAN FIRST OF ALL I
THINK ALL OF OUR SCENARIOS ARE
INFORMED BY A LOT OF INPUT AND
YOU KNOW SCENARIO FOR. OUR
ALTERNATIVE FOR- AT YOU KNOW WAS
INFORMED BY INPUT FROM- FROM
STAKEHOLDERS- AND- AND I GUESS I
WOULD ALSO ADD THAT. ANY OF
THESE SCENARIOS WE CAN BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE ON DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES WITHIN THOSE
SCENARIOS- SO AS WE AS WE PICK
THE DIFFERENT SCENARIOS WE CAN
ALSO HIGHLIGHT KIND OF EARLY
ACTION AND YOU KNOW THIS WILL BE
A KIND OF A REALLY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION THAT THE BOARD HAS
WHEN IT- IS PRESENTED WITH THE
SCENARIOS AND HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW
THE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS THE
COSTS THAT YOU KNOW THE OVERALL
EFFECT ON GDP- EFFECT ON JOBS-
AND THE BENEFITS OF EACH
SCENARIO AND- LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENT. STRATEGIES WITHIN
THEM AND HIGHLIGHTING YOU KNOW
ARE THERE OPPORTUNITIES TO GO-
FASTER WITH PARTICULAR STRATEGY
SO THAT'LL ALL BE PART OF THE
BOARD CONVERSATION IN JUNE OKAY
YEAH WE JUST- TO CONSIDERATION
OF THAT OF THAT THIS AGGRESSIVE
ACTIONS IN SYRIA ONE. BUT GIVING
IT MORE TIME FRAME- YEAH AND I
AND I ALSO YOU KNOW. A LOT OF
THE STRATEGIES LIKE FOR INSTANCE
ONE OF THE KEY DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN ALTERNATIVE ONE AND
ALTERNATIVE THREE IS. OUR RATE
OF ASSUMPTIONS ON OUR VEHICLE
TRANSITIONS AND OUR RATE OF
ASSUMPTIONS ON BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION YOU KNOW AND CAN
CAN THE RATE OF THOSE
TRANSFORMATIONS. BE SPED UP AND
YOU KNOW THE- THE INVESTMENTS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE IN
THOSE AREAS AND LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AND HOPEFULLY THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET I THINK WILL WILL HELP-
IN OUR STATE IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGY FOR THE- SEVENTY PP BE
OZONE STANDARD WHICH HAS TO BE
MET BY TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN. YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE STRATEGIES WERE
THINKING ABOUT IN THAT PLAN IS
YOU KNOW CAN WE MOVE- ARE DIESEL
TRUCKS OFF THE ROAD WHEN THEY
FINISH THEIR D. USEFUL LIFE LIKE
WHAT ARE SOME STRATEGIES AROUND
THAT ARE THEIR INCENTIVE
STRATEGIES AROUND THAT ARE THERE
REGULATORY STRATEGIES LIKE. WHAT
ARE WAYS THAT WE CAN ACCELERATE-
MOVING THOSE VEHICLES OFF THE
ROAD SO THOSE ARE THE KIND OF
THINGS THAT WE CAN THINK ABOUT
REALLY- PUTTING THE PEDAL TO THE
METAL AND MAKING. PROGRESS- IN
MEETING THE GOALS. MAYBE ONE
MORE THEY'LL GIVE TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO CAN TEACH IS
QUESTION I AM THERE. IT LOOKS
LIKE THERE. IN THE WAY. THAT
COVERS INTERPRETING SB ONE
HUNDRED- THEY'RE STILL
CONSIDERABLE EMISSIONS COMING
FROM ELECTRICITY EVEN IN A- IN
IN ALL SCENARIOS WILL ACCEPT
SCENARIO ONE- SO YOU KNOW 80%
REDUCTION EMISSIONS MEANS ABOUT
THE MEASURE OUT EIGHTY MILLION
METRIC ONS- FOR THE WHOLE
ECONOMY SO WE HAVE THIRTY
MILLION METRIC TONS LEFT OVER
FROM ELECTRICITY. W. A LARGE
PART OF REMAINING EMISSIONS SO
THIS WINDOW IS WE FEEL LIKE WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO MUCH BETTER
THAN THAT I THINK THEY WERE
EXPECTING TO GET TO THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION METRIC TONS BY TWENTY
THIRTY OF ELECTRICITY SECTOR
FROM CORRECT- SO I WOULD JUST
URGE BUT YOU KNOW AGAIN EXCEPT
FOR DINNER WHILE THEY'RE STILL A
LOT OF EMISSIONS WATCHERS THE
SECTOR FEELS THAT WE SHOULD GO
TO DRIVE OUT. SO THE ONE OF THE
EIGHT. I AM WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS ONE OF THOSE AREAS
I THINK IT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT- TO KNOW THAT.
IMPLEMENTATION IS SO IMPORTANT.
IN ORDER TO MEET OUR SB ONE
HUNDRED GOALS THERE NEEDS TO BE
SIGNIFICANT DEPLOYMENT OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY RESOURCES AND I
JUST WANT TO. I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE KNOWS YOU
KNOW THOSE PROJECTS NEED TO. TO
BE PERMITTED THEY NEED TO BE
APPROVED THEY NEED TO BE. BUILT
AND- AND WE NEED TO STAY ON THAT
TRAJECTORY TO MAKE HUGE
PROGRESS- IN THAT CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION- AND- I NEVER MISS
HAPPEN OP. I HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO KIND OF MAKE THAT EDITORIAL
COMMENT THAT WE HAVE TO WE HAVE
TO DEPLOY DEPLOY DEPLOY- AND
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE- A
LOT OF THOSE DECISIONS ARE.
LOCAL DECISIONS AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY- CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN SO THAT WE ARE GETTING.
THE STEEL IN THE GROUND THAT.
GREENS OUR ECONOMY AND CREATE
JOBS. AGREED VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SARAH STERN. THANK
YOU- TWENTY MAKE UP A
ABBREVIATED COMMENT AND-
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE VICE
CHAIRS- URGINGS OF CONSIDERATION
ON THAT AGGRESSIVENESS I'M IN
THE NEAR TERM. AND NOT GETTING
STUCK IN IN THE IMPASSE THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO JUST WAIT ON.
OTHER AGENCIES OR OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES FOR MERGING BUT I'M
I'M REALLY PLEASED TO HEAR YOU
OCCUPY THAT ROLE AS CHAIR OF THE
LEAD AIR POLLUTION REGULATOR AND
USING THOSE A FORTIES THAT YOU
HAVE- UNDER SB THIRTY TWO IN
ANOTHER AREAS OF LAW. BUT ALSO
YOU KNOW AT THE OUTSET. WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE AVOIDED AIR
QUALITY RELATED DEATHS THAT WERE
AVOIDING IN THE STATE BECAUSE OF
OUR PROGRESS AND CONTINUING TO
ROUTE THIS WORK IN PUBLIC HEALTH
I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE WE
CAN DO ON THE REGULATORY SIDE
FOR DIRECT EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
RIGHT NOW. I THINK THAT HAS TO
DO WITH OUR HOW WE ACHIEVE OUR
SIP. I THINK THAT HAS TO DO WITH
HOW MOBILE SOURCE RULES- ARE
ROLLED OUT AND I WOULD APPLAUD
YOU FOR WHAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING
ON THE LIGHT DUTY FRONT I THINK
WE CAN DO EVEN MORE. I MEAN ANY
MORE LIGHT DUTY I KNOW IT'S JUST
A ADDITIONAL PROPOSAL BUT- I
THINK WE CAN BE BOLDER AND I
THINK IN THE LEGISLATURE WE NEED
TO GIVE YOU SPACE TO BE THAT
BOLD AND LET YOU KNOW THAT WERE
WITH YOU- AND- AND THE SAME GOES
ON. ON ALL THESEOTHER SECTORS
ON THE POWER FRONT ON THE
INDUSTRIAL FRONT- YOU KNOW. THE
MARKETS NOT GONNA SOLVE THIS
WHOLE PROBLEM. AND I THINK
THAT'S THE REALIZATION IS THAT
CABIN TRAITS NOT GONNA SOLVE.
THIS CRISIS AND- M. IT'S GOING
TO BE THERE- AND I DO THINK
WE'RE GONNA NEED THOSE MARKET
MECHANISMS BUT I'M I'M I'M JUST
. I'M I'M HEARTENED TO HEAR YOU
FOCUS ON THE DETAILS OF THE
SECTORAL SORT OF DIRECT
EMISSIONS APPROACHES. AND NOT
ALSO JUST BETTING ON UNTESTED
TECHNOLOGIES WAY TO GET US
THERE. BECAUSE WE ARE GONNA HAVE
TO LOOK AT THE CARBON REMOVAL
QUESTION. AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE
TECHNOLOGY SCENARIOS. WORKED IN
CARBON REMOVAL THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER AND YOU KNOW WATCHING
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION. AROUND THAT
GREAT PROMISE OF CARBON CAPTURE.
AND YOU KNOW EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS LATER ON FUTURE CHEN YOU
HAVE A HAWKING MASS SITTING IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS COUNTRY THAT
ISN'T DOING ANYTHING IS
COMPLETELY DISMANTLE. AND SO I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF ENERGY AND
ENTHUSIASM ABOUT EXCITING NEW
TECHNOLOGY IDEAS BUILDING
ELECTROLYZER IS FOR HYDROGEN
AND- GOING BIG ON. YOU KNOW
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE IN IN
INTO INDUSTRIAL AND EVEN INTO
THE OIL SECTOR BUT I. WE HAVE A
STE APPROACH A SERIES OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORKING. AND
THEY'RE LITERALLY TRANSFORMING
THE ENTIRE GLOBAL MARKET JUST
FROM DOING THE BASIC STICKING OF
THOSE FUNDAMENTALS CLEAN AIR.
OUR STANDARDS NO ALL THE SPACE
THAT WE WERE JUST GIVEN FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT TO ME
IS A SIGNAL THAT CALIFORNIA IS
PUT IN. UNFORTUNATELY THE
SITUATION WHERE THE WHOLE
COUNTRY'S GOING TO COUNT ON US
TO KEEP LEADING. AND WE HAVEN'T
SEEN. AT LEAST FROM A FROM A
REGULATORY OR LEGISLATIVE
PERSPECTIVE CONGRESS BE ABLE TO
ACT BUT- BUT I DON'T JUST WANT
TO CHASE. YOU KNOW TAX CREDITS
OR SORT OF NEAR TERM BUDGET
OPPORTUNITIES AND LET THAT DRIVE
OUR POLICY. I THINK WE'VE GOT TO
STICK TO DOING THIS THE
CALIFORNIA WAY AND- AND I THINK
THAT MEANS JUSTICE IN JOBS
FIRST. AND I THINK WE CAN GET
THAT DONE SO I APPRECIATE THE
HEARING TODAY AND LET HIM LET ME
MAKE A FEW REMARKS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THERE IS IF YOU
HAVE A- FEW MINUTES I THE NEXT
QUESTION. I KNOW THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME IMPORTANT.
CARBON CAPTURE BILLS COMING TO
YOUR YOUR COMMITTEE. YEAH IF I
CAN- JUST JUMP RIGHT IN AND ASK
A QUESTION DIRECTLY RELEVANT O
ADD TO. THIS TOPIC SO I CHAIR
RANDOLPH- AS A DOCTOR GROUP
WHITE- REFER TO IT IT APPEARS
THAT CARP IS ASSUMING THAT
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
TECHNOLOGY HAS A CAPTURE RATE OF
90% AND YET- COURTING TO.
BACKGROUND INFORMATION THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO THIS COMMITTEE THERE
THERE ARE TWO SPECIFIC PROJECTS
FOR EXAMPLETHE PETRA NOTEBOOK
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
PROJECT IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON ONE OF THE LARGEST
CCS PLANTS IN THE WORLD REPORTED
A 33% CAPTURE RATE. AND ANOTHER
PROJECT THIS SHIP THE SHELL
QUEST CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
PROJECT IN CANADA REPORTED ONLY
CAPTURING 48% SO HOW IS IT THAT
THAT CARP CAN ASSUME A CAPTURE
RATE OF 90% AS PART AS PART OF
ITS-IT'S A- SCOPING PLAN.
DELIBERATIONS SO IT D. M. WE
HAVE. LITERATURE ANALYSIS THAT
WILL BE YOU KNOW PRESENTED IN
THE DRAFT SCOPING PLAN THAT
TALKS ABOUT THE DIFFERENT A
POTENTIAL RATES OF CARBON
CAPTURE- AND IT CAN BE AS HIGH
AS NINETY PERCENT- BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE- ITO SORT
OF WE WERE TALKING EARLIER
ABOUT- UNIT YOU IDENTIFY A
STRATEGY. YOU IDENTIFY THE
UNCERTAINTIES WITH THAT STRATEGY
RATELIKE WE ALREADY KNOW AT
THIS POINT THAT- IT'S SORT OF
THE DEPLOYMENT OF CCS PROJECTS
IS PROBABLY NOT GOING TO B. AS
QUICKLY AS OUR INITIAL MODELING
IS ASSUMING AND WILL PROBABLY
HAVE TO ADJUST THAT- AND- AND
THEN WE MAY NEED TO WOULD MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS AS WE LEARN MORE
ABOUT WHAT THE ACTUAL RATE OF
CAPTURE IS- SO. WE WILL BE YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT ALL OF THOSE
ISSUES AS PART OF THE DISCUSSION
AROUND THE DRAFT- AND WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE SHARING OF DATA
THAT FOLKS CAN KIND OF. PICK
APART AND TAKE A LOOK AT ADD TO
AND COMMENT ON AS PART OF THE
PROCESS MMHM. OKAY I GUESS THE
CONCERN THAT WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE- FACING NOW IS THAT.
MANY WHERE WHERE WE'RE HEARING
FROM. FROM FROM THE OIL INDUSTRY
FROM FROM THE- THE- THE BUILDING
ENTREES THAT REPRESENT- THE
FOSSIL FUEL WORKERS THAT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO. PHASE OUT ANY
FOSSIL FUELS BECAUSE CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE IS JUST
GOING TO CAPTURE MAGICALLY
CAPTURE ALL THE CARBON AND WE
CAN CONTINUE TO DRILL AND RELY
ON FOSSIL FUELS. AND SO. YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE HOW YOU YOU DON'T MISS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO STRESS THE
URGENCY OF DEPLOYING AND
PERMITTING RENEWABLE PROJECTS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. I MEAN UNDER
ANY SCENARIO THAT THAT THE A. R.
B. IS A CONSIDERING NOW DO DO
YOU DO YOU SEE ANY SCENARIO
WHERE WE CAN REALISTICALLY
ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
BEFORE TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANTLY FOCUSING
ON PHASING OUT OUR RELIANCE ON
FOSSIL FUELS- 1100% I MEAN WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO PHASE OUT
FOSSIL FUEL. COMBUSTION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO MEET OUR
GOALS AND THAT IS. YOU KNOW THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF MANY OF THE
PIECES OF OUR PORTFOLIO. BUT
EVEN IF WE DO THAT EVEN IF WE
ARE SUCCESSFUL IN THAT WE STILL
HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
INTERNAL COMBUSTION VEHICLES ON
THE ROAD. WE HAVE EXISTING
BUILDING SO THAT ALL ARE SET UP
TO USE FOSSIL FUELS WE HAVE
INDUSTRIAL PROCESSES WHERE WE
HAVE NOT YET IDENTIFIED. A ZERO
CARBON ALTERNATIVE FOR HOW THEY
OPERATE- AND SO IT'S A THOSE
EMISSIONS THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
BE THINKING ABOUT. HOW CAN WE-
CAPTURE THOSE EMISSIONS AT THE
SOURCE AND HOW COULD WE DO
DIRECT AIR CAPTURE AND WHAT ARE
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE AS A
STATE CAN SUPPORT AND DEPLOY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. ANY SO IN
OUR BASE. MY ON OKAY- THESE
THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE ALWAYS
FASCINATING TO ME BECAUSE- IN WE
THROW AROUND TERMS LIKE JUSTICE
ANY THROW AROUND TERMS LIKE-
LIKE EQUITY- AND SO. WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL COSTS ARE-
THE ONE QUESTION THAT I'D LOVE
TO BE ABLE TO ASK YOU ABOUT ALL
THESE DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES IS-
WHAT WHAT'S THE ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS OF THE IMPACT THAT IT
WILL HAVE ON OUR GDP IN IN
CALIFORNIA BETWEEN EACH OF THE
ALTERNATIVES BECAUSE THERE IS
GOING TO BE. TO BE A COST AND
THEN THE OTHER PART OF THIS THAT
I'M ALWAYS VERY FASCINATED- A BY
IS A WHAT THE REST OF THE WORLD
THINKS AS WELL- I MIGHT BEEN ON
RECORD- AS YOU DELVE I STILL GOT
SCARS I'M OVER. CAP AND TRADE-
THAT RUN PRETTY DEEP- AND I FELT
AT THE TIME WAS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO BECAUSE CALIFORNIA DOES
HAVE TO LEAD WE NEED. TO GET TO
A PLACE BUT NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE REST THE
WORLD OR WE STOP PULLING CARBON
OUT OF THE DIRT- AND PUTTING IN
THE ATMOSPHERE AT SOME POINT WE
HAVE TO GET IT OUT OF THE
ATMOSPHERE AT ATMOSPHERE. AND
PUTTING IT BACK INTO BACK INTO
THE GROUND THAT'S THAT'S
ABSOLUTELYTRUE WE'VE GOT TO
WE'VE GOT TO DO THAT. BUT THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE DO THAT
WITHOUT RUINING OUR ECONOMY. AND
IT'S FASCINATING ONE WHEN YOU
BRING THIS UP- BECAUSE PEOPLE
SAY ALL THERE YOU GO AGAIN CHAD
YOU KNOW- YOU MUST BE THERE'S
YOUR CONSERVATIVE SIDE COMING
OUT AGAIN WHERE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. TALKING ABOUT THE ECONOMY
WELL YOU KNOW MOM SAID- BACK
WHEN I WAS A KID THAT MONEY
DOESN'T GROW ON TREES- AND THAT
WAS TRUE THEN AND IT IS STILL.
TRUE TODAY AND WE HAVE TO HAVE
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT IT'S
GOING TO COST. WHERE CALIFORNIA
IS GOING TO LEAD NOT JUST IN THE
U. S. THE IMPACT BECAUSE YOU'RE
RIGHT THE REST OF THE COUNTRY IS
WATCHING US. THE END THEY'RE
WATCHING TO SEE WHAT IMPACT-
THIS IS ALL GOING TO HAVE HERE.
BEFORE THE BEFORE BUT NATIONALLY
WE'RE GOING TO ACT. AND IT'S
ALSO FASCINATING ESPECIALLY
RIGHT NOW WHEN I WATCH EVERY
SINGLE DAY. IN THE NEWS ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING OVER IN EUROPE.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE
ARE- I'LL CALL THEM DICTATORS
BRUTAL DICTATORS- THAT ARE A
POUNCING ON COUNTRIES RIGHT NEXT
TO THEM- OVER. OIL AND- AND
THAT'S WHAT THAT IS ALL ABOUT
IT'S ABOUT OIL AND GAS I'M
SEEING THE REST OF EUROPE. AND
WHO SAID THAT THEY'RE GONNA MOVE
A TO HAVE A SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
PORTFOLIO. ON WHERE THEY'RE
STILL A BOOK OF NOT WILLING TO
STEP UP. YOU TALK ABOUT MORE
JUSTICE AND TALK ABOUT MORALITY-
STILL NOT WILLING TO BUILD A
PULL THE PLUG ON THEIR- OIL AND
GAS BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THAT IT'S GOING TO
HAVE BECAUSE THEY THINK THAT
IT'S GOING TO HAVE. AN IMPACT ON
THEIR ON IN DECREASING THEIR
THEIR GDP SO WE HAVE TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THIS. A FROM A
FROM ECONOMIC. TERM I IN
ECONOMIC TERMS AS WELL. AS OF
THE ONE THING IN THE DOCUMENTS
THAT I HAVE I DON'T HAVE- YOU
KNOW WITH ALL THE FOR
ALTERNATIVES- WHAT ARE THE
IMPACT OF THIS IS GOING TO HAVE.
IS IT GOING TO HAVE NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON OUR- ON CALIFORNIA'S
GDP- IS IT GOING TO BE A NET
POSITIVE- AND HOW DO WE GET
THEM. TO OUR GOALS A REDUCING
OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT AT THE SAME
TIME MAKING SURE. THAT WE HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY. BUT SO THAT
IS THE KEY YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
KEY ISSUES THAT THE BOARD WILL
NEED TO CONSIDER WHEN IT REVIEWS
THE DRAFT PLAN IN JUNE BECAUSE
EACH OF THESE ALTERNATIVES. HAS
HAS PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS AND-
AND COSTS BUT THEY SHOW. YOU TO
THE ALTERNATIVE SHOWS A GROWING
ECONOMY AND WE CAN CONSISTENTLY
HAVE A GROWING ECONOMY AND THEN
THE QUESTION IS JUST SORT OF-
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH- OF- YOU KNOW.
HOW MUCH WILL THE ECONOMIC.
IMPACT OF EACH ALTERNATIVE BE IN
THE CONTEXT OF THAT GROWING
ECONOMY. I'M AND- AND SO THAT'LL
BE WHAT THE BOARD WILL BE
CONSIDERING AS IT WEIGHS. ON
EACH OF THE DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES AND WHAT- THE
AFFECTED EACH OF THE
ALTERNATIVES WILL BE I MEAN I
WILL NOTE THAT WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT. SORT OF THE TIMELINE AND
ARE YOU LOOKING AT TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE ARE YOU LOOKING AT TWNTY
FORTY FIVE. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
AT. THE BENEFITS YOU ACHIEVE IF
YOU GIVE YOURSELF A LITTLE MORE
RUNWAY IN TERMS OF A TIME LINE.
IS THAT YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SEE COSTS COME DOWN. AND YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SEE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES- COME ONLINE IN A
WAY THAT REDUCES. THE FINANCIAL
IMPACTS- TO CONSUMERS OF THE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES. YOU KNOW
AS THE REDUCTION WE HAVE SEEN IN
THE COST OF BOTH. VEHICLE
BATTERIES AND IT YEAH-
INDUSTRIAL SCALE- BATTERIES FOR
ENERGY STORAGE. YOU CAN SEE
THESE TREND LINES YOU CAN SEE
THE TREND LINES OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY- YOU KNOW WIND SOLAR.
THOSE STRATEGIES GOING DOWN- AND
IF YOU GIVE YOURSELF A LITTLE
MORE RUNWAY- A TWO. X. X. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE COST
BENEFITS- THAN THAT CAN MAKE THE
WHOLE TRANSITION. MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR RESIDENTS IN THE
STATE. OTHER QUESTIONS I THINK
SOME OF OUR GREAT WAS CHAIRED.
THE ISSUE OF ALLOWANCES-
CONSISTENTLY COMES UP. AND YOU
KNOW JUST THE TOO MANY
ALLOWANCES. ALTER THAT MAY NOT
BE- HELP IN STABILIZE YOU KNOW
THE EFFORTS THAT ARE UNDERWAY.
CHAIR CAN YOU KIND OF GIVE US
SOME THOUGHTS ON WHAT OPTIONS
IMPOSSIBLE- YOU KNOW. CORRECTION
THAT THE WE AT THE BOARD MIGHT
BE GOING IN AND PERHAPS ALSO
DOMINO'S SPOKE ABOUT- THE
ALLOWANCES MAY HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS AND IDEAS AS WELL I
THINK THAT'S A HUGE TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION THAT COMES UP-
CONSISTENTLY AND SO WANT TO HEAR
YOUR THOUGHTS AND I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS
WATCHING ONE IN HERE YOUR
RESPONSES. YEAH I MEAN IT'S
ABSOLUTELY M. A. AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR US TO ADDRESS- AND SO
OUR PLAN IS THAT WE WILL
COMPLETE THE SCOPING PLAN AND
THEN AS PART OF OUR
IMPLEMENTATION STEPS- WE WILL BE
TAKING A LOOK AT- AT CAP AND
TRADE AND WE WILL LOOK AT THAT
QUESTION OF- YOU KNOW HOW TO
ADDRESS A ALLOWANCES WE WILL
LOOK AT AND REGULATORY-
PROVISIONS LAKE- THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD AND OTHER THINGS-
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THAT BE DONE. AS
PART OF THAT ROBUST REGULATORY
PROCESS BECAUSE THERE ARE A BY A
WIDE RANGE OF OPINIONS OUT
THERE. ABOUT SORT OF WHAT THE
BEST WAY TO DO IT I MEAN AS AS
DALLAS MENTION THERE'S DIFFERENT
WAYS TO KIND OF TACKLE THE ISSUE
AND IT HAS DIFFERENT SORT OF
EFFECTS ON THE PROGRAM IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. AND SORT OF
HAVING IT BE PART OF A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT. WHAT CHANGES
TO THE PROGRAMMER NEEDED WHAT
UPDATES CAN HAPPEN AND HOW THOSE
UPDATES CAN BE STRUCTURED IN A
WAY. THAT PROVIDES KIND OF THE
REGULATORY CERTAINTY THAT WE
NEED- IS ED YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET ALL OF THE ALL
OF YOU POINTS AND ALL OF THAT-
THE- PUBLIC IMPACT AND SO. WE
WILL EMBARK ON THAT PROCESS AS
SOON AS WE'RE DONE WITH THE
SKIPPING PLAN. THOUSAND OF
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANTED
TO ADD. TANK YOU. I THINK I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT WE ARE WAY
BEYOND THE EITHER OR OR KIND OF
CONVERSATION THAT WE WERE HAVING
OVER A DECADE AGO- I THINK WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE GOING
THERE NEED TO BE A ROCK VARIETY
OF DIRECT REGULATORY MEASURES.
AND PROGRAMS AND STANDARDS TO
ACHIEVE DIRECTED MARVEL BENEFITS
AND SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES AND AT
THE SAME TIME WE NEED TO INSERT
TO THE MAXIMUM EXTENT POSSIBLE
COST EFFECTIVENESS IN ACHIEVING
THE STATE'S. GOALS AS WELL FOR
MEMBERS MAYES WAS REFERRING TO
AND I THINK THAT THE CLIMATE
POLICY PORTFOLIO HAS TO WEAVE
THESE TWO APPROACHES TOGETHER.
WHAT'S REALLY CRUCIAL IS THAT TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU HAVE SUCCESS
AND ONE THAT IT NOT A ROAD THE
INFLUENCE OF THE OTHER. SO WHEN
WE HAVE A THEIR CARBON MARKET IN
PLACE IN THE OTHER REGULATORY
PROGRAMS OR HOPEFULLY
INCREASINGLY SUCCESSFUL EVEN
GOING SO FAR AS REDUCING VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED BUT IN ANY CASE
VEHICLE FUEL EFFICIENCY IN
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ETCETERA. THEN
THAT CAN POTENTIALLY FREE UP
ALLOWANCES. ABOUT AFFECT YOU
PUSH DOWN IN ONE PLACE THE SAME
EMISSIONS POP UP SOMEWHERE ELSE
AND ALL THAT HAPPENS IS THE
PRICE OF ALLOWANCES FALL IN THAT
REMOVES THE INCENTIVE IN THAT
CONSTRUCTIVE ROLE. THAT THE
MARKET CAN PLAY SO WE'RE
ADVOCATING FOR A MARKET DESIGN
THAT ALIGNS TO THE MARKET WITH
THE REGULATORY MEASURES AND SO
THAT THEY WORK TOGETHER AND
REINFORCE THE INCENTIVE FOR
DIRECT ACTION THROUGH
REGULATIONS THE ACTIONS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND INDEPENDENT
ACTORS AND FIRMS. IT'S SUCH A
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND NOT HAVE
THAT BOUNCE BACK IN A ROW THE
EFFECT OF THE MARKET. THAT'S
WHAT'S AT THE HEART OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAVE. THANK
YOU HOW HIGH ON THE THINGS TO DO
LIST SHOULD THIS BE ON IN TERMS
OF- WHEN WE- I. GET CLOSE TO
WRAPPING UP THE SCOPING PLAN I
MEAN. YOU KNOW IT COULD BE. I
GET HOME ON THURSDAY EVENINGS
AND I GOT A HONEY DO LIST THAT I
GOT TO TAKE CARE OF AND- AND
THEY'RE RANKED IN. TERMS OF
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT GIVEN THE
- FOUR DAYS THAT I'VE BEEN GONE
RIGHT AND SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ALLOWANCES WHERE WHERE
DOES THIS. OR SHOULD IT FALL. IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO. GET US.
STRAINED OUT LITTLE BIT IN TERMS
OF ALL OF THE- DISCUSSIONS AND
WE WERE JUST HAVING WITH OUR-
GOOD FRIENDS. IN THE SENATE I
MEAN DOES IT UP THERE IS IT IN
BETWEEN. BOB I WILL GO AHEAD-
YOU KNOW I MEAN I GUESS I WOULD
SAY THAT THAT AN IMPORTANT NEXT
STEP ANYTIME YOU ADOPT YOU KNOW
AFTER YOU ADOPT THE SCOPING
PLAN- AND AFTER WE HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY COLLECTS TO COLLECT
DATA BASED ON THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AS IT CURRENTLY EXISTS
RATE LIKE YOU KNOW IT'S IT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO KIND OF
TAKE A LOOK AT THE PROGRAM AND
SEE WHAT CHANGES NEED TO BE
MADE- AND THERE COULD BE CHANGES
MADE FOR IT YOU KNOW IN ANY
NUMBER OF AREAS THAT WE COULD
CONSIDER. AND I GUESS I THINK OF
IT KIND OF AS A LAWYER RIGHT
ONCE YOU OPEN UP A REGULATION
LAKE SAYS SOMETHING AS COMPLEX
AS CAP AND TRADE THERE'S GOING
TO BE A LOT OF ISSUES THAT COME
UP AND WILL BE PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION- SO I THINK OF ALL
THOSE ISSUES AS KIND OF
PROCEEDING TOGETHER RIGHT LIKE
ALL OF THE ADVOCACY THAT WE HAVE
GOTTEN OVER TIME IT ALL SORT OF
COULD BECOMES PART OF THE
DISCUSSION- AND- AND SO WE WILL
FINISH THE COPING PLAN WE WILL
YOU KNOW COLLECT MORE DATA ON
THE PROGRAM AS IT EXISTS NOW.
THEN THE FUN BEGINS. IF I MAY
COMMENT I WOULD SEPARATE THE
QUESTION IN THE ALLOWANCE MARKET
INTO SORT OF TWO PARTS ONE IS TO
DO WITH THE STRUCTURE OF THE
MARKET SUCH THAT IT'S DESIGNED
TO WORK WELL WITH THE OTHER
REGULATORY INITIATIVES AND I
WOULD PUT THAT HIGH ON THE TO DO
LIST BECAUSE I THINK IT CAN BE
DONE. RELATIVELY STAND
STRAIGHTFORWARD WAY WITH IT WITH
THE EXERCISING EXISTING
REGULATORY AUTHORITY JUST IN THE
WAY THAT A OR B. HAS USE THAT
AUTHORITY PREVIOUSLY SO FOR AS I
MENTIONED FOR EXAMPLE THE
INTRODUCTION OF ADDITIONAL PRICE
STEPS OR SOMETHING SO THE MARKET
AUTOMATICALLY RESPONDS TO OTHER
INITIATIVES THAT THE STATE IS
MAKING. THEM THERE IS A BIGGER
THINK. THE ONLY A BIGGER THING
BECAUSE IT'S PROBABLY TO PUT TO
COME TO A DECISION IS A HARDER
THING TO DO. ABOUT ADJUSTING THE
OVERALL SUPPLY IN A DIRECTED WAY
BY PERHAPS REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF ALLOWANCES THAT ARE ISSUED
EACH YEAR I ALSO THINK THAT
THAT'S- VERY IMPORTANT AND- AND
INCREASINGLY URGENT BUT- IT
INCREASINGLY WERE IS GOING TO
REQUIRE A PROCESS THAT I'M SURE
CHIU AROUND OFF WILL. LOSE A LOT
OF SLEEP OVER BEFORE RESOLUTION
ABOUT DECISION COMES TOGETHER I
KNOW THAT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO DO THAT. BUT I.
WOULD NOT WANT TO HOLD THE ONE
FOR THE OTHER AND I THINK THAT.
MARKET REDESIGNED COULD HAPPEN
AN EXPEDITED WAY. I THINK JUST
THE- LINE OF QUESTIONS MAY BE
CAUSING A LOT OF PEOPLE
WATCHING- TO NOT HAVE SOME GOOD
NIGHTS OF SLEEP. IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS AND- MONTHS AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE- I KNOW THERE ARE. TWO
SIDES TO THIS DISCUSSION- AND-
THEY BALK TO US AND ASKED US YOU
KNOW- TO THE CONSIDERED ONE
ACTION OR OR THE OTHER I. I'M OF
THE MINDSET THAT WE DO HAVE AN
OVER ABUNDANCE OF ALLOWANCES UP
THERE AND- THERE WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER. YOU
TOUCHED ON VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED IN AND I KNOW. ALL OF
US UP HERE ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S. ORDERS TO
ELECTRIFY OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM I HAVE A- VESTED INTEREST
GIVEN THE- NATURE OF THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT IN THE
ROLE THEY CAN PLAY. I JUST FOR
THE STATE BUT NATIONALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO. PROVIDING THE
ESSENTIAL RESOURCE- THAT-
STORAGE BATTERY ENERGY STORAGE
REQUIRES AS WELL AS VEHICLES.
HOW ARE WE IN AND LOVE TO HEAR
YOUR THOUGHTS HAVE EVERYONE
ACROSS THE PANELS HERE- WE
THINKING ABOUT THOSE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE. WHO LIVE IN MULTI FAMILY
HOMES WHO DON'T HAVE STREET
PARKING WHO DON'T. DON'T FIT
INTO THIS EQUATION OF EVERYONE
WILL HAVE AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE IN
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE.
AVAILABLE EVERYWHERE- LOVE TO
HEAR WHAT THE THOUGHTS ARE ON
THAT BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT AGAIN DON'T FIT
INTO. THAT PARTICULAR. FORMULA
THAT- THAT WERE PURSUING
CURRENTLY. N. DA AND WE
REPRESENT COMMUNITIES THAT- TO
FIT INTO. THAT PARTICULAR TARGET
POPULATION THAT- THAT ARE
CONCERNED. FROM MANY ASPECTS- OF
TRYING TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL.
OKAY I'LL START M. I WOULD SAY
AS A COUPLE THINGS I MEAN YOU
KNOW. IT IS IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE- PROVIDING THE ZERO
EMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE
NEED TO SUPPORT THIS YEAR
MISSION MOBILITY THAT WE WANT TO
SEE AN END SO WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND
THE CPC AND OTHERS- TO THINK
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE
STRATEGIES AROUND- TACKLING SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES TACKLING RURAL
CHARGING. TACKLING MULTI FAMILY-
CHARGING YOU KNOW THINKING
ABOUT- YOU KNOW CHARGING PAUSES
AND WORKPLACE CHARGING AND
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN THEIR KIND OF LAND USE ROLE-
WHERE CAN THEY LOCATE CHARGING
THAT THERE AT RESIDENTS CAN USE-
AND ALSO KIND OF TO YOUR POINT
RECOGNIZING THAT- NOT EVERYONE-
HAS- ACCESS TO- A BRAND NEW CAR
RATE- AND SO HAVING THEM.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RESIDENTS TO-
PURCHASE- YOU KNOW DEVELOPING A
ROBUST SECONDARY MARKET ENSURING
THAT THAT'S THAT THOSE VEHICLES
ARE IN THE SECONDARY MARKET
ENSURING THAT THE ROBUST- AND-
AND- CONTINUING TO WORK TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE. A WIDE
SUITE OF CHARGING OPTIONS OF
THAT FOLKS CAN USE- IS PART OF
ALL THE IMPLEMENTATION WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING. BRIEFLY THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE MY PORTFOLIO
BUT I WILL MAKE TAKE OBVIOUS
SUB- ENDORSED OBVIOUS
OBSERVATION THAT SHARON OFF MADE
EARLIER ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT I
MEAN I SAW THIS BACK. IN MY
EARLIER DAYS FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
BREAKOUT OF INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
IN ORANGE COUNTY IN THE
SEVENTIES THE REPAIR WORK
REQUIRES A TURNAROUND AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL AND WE
CAN'T JUST SAY IT'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DOING SOMETHING
WRONG I THINK THE STATE IS TO
PROVIDE THE PROPER KIND OF
INCENTIVES AND DIRECTOR FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN ORDER TO
EXPLOIT CERTAIN TYPES OF.
FIGHTING AND I THINK THAT WAS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
THE STATE FACES BUT SPECIFICALLY
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF MY
PORTFOLIO ON THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM I WILL POINT BACK TO THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND IN
THE ROLE OF INVESTMENTS ARE
PROBABLY INVESTMENTS. YOU KNOW
THE MAJORITY OF US WAS BY FAR
HAVE TO COME FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR BUT THOSE INVESTMENTS GET
COORDINATED INTENSE AND DIRECTED
THROUGH THE ROLE OF THE OF THE
STATE AND- IN PUTTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE. OTHERS
BEEN OVER SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS INVESTED THROUGH THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
TODAY AND THAT THE REFORMS THAT
I WAS SUGGESTING IN MY REMARKS
COULD ACTUALLY ACCELERATE THE
AROUND REVENUE GOING TO THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION. BONTA
BRIDGE PARTY ABOUT THAT FURTHER
OFF SO I THINK I'M- I'M I'M SURE
THAT THERE ARE OUTAGES ON THE
JACKET SUCH ABOUT HOW TO CHANNEL
THOSE- INVESTMENTS SUCH AS THE
ADDRESS EVERY TYPE OF COMMUNITY
WHERE THERE IS AREN'T OBVIOUS
UPPER MIDDLE INCOME. HOUSEHOLDS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CAPTURE THE ADVANTAGES OF A
PROGRAMS THAT ARE EXISTING
ALREADY- SO LET ME NOT DEFER.
THE CATHERINE. THANK DOLLARS.
I'M SO FIRST JUST TO A FIRM I
DON'T THINK IT CAN BE SAID
ENOUGH NOT EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO OWN AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE THAT'S NOT A
SUSTAINABLE OR REALISTIC MODEL
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
STRIVING FOR. IT'S NOT
AFFORDABLE FOR EVERYBODY IT'S
NOT ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYBODY AND
IT'S NOT PREFERRED BY EVERYBODY-
IT IS PART OF WHAT I SPOKE TO
AND I WAS JUST MENTIONED IN
TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
INVESTMENTS ARE TAILORED TO OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES- WE HAVE A LOT
OF FARMWORKERS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY THAT UTILIZE
THINGS LIKE. VAN PULLS ON THE
GREEN RIGHT TERRACE PROGRAM IN
THE CITY OF YOUR HONEST BECOME
PRETTY WELL KNOWN AND POPULAR.
THERE'S CARD SURE AND RIGHT SURE
OPPORTUNITIES WE NEED MORE BUS
AND TRANSIT FOR WHERE THERE IS-
COMPACT AND DENSE ENOUGH
DEVELOPMENT TO BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN THAT. AND I THINK
PARTICULARLY WHAT I WOULD
EMPHASIZE FOR THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND THEIR ROLE IN
OVERSEEING TARGETS FOR VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. IS TRYING TO
MOTIVATE THAT- COUPLING RIGHT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
TRANSPORTATION THAT ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF
THEIR BASIC DAILY NEEDS WITHOUT
HAVING TO RELY ON SINGLE
PASSENGER VEHICLES. TO GET
AROUND. THANK YOU- PROGRAMS WERE
FAMILIAR WITH THE- INOTES-
RADION GETS A SHOUT OUT MAYOR
RADION FROM YOUR ON WITH FOR THE
GREEN BAY TITLES PROGRAM THAT
HE'S ACTUALLY. EXPANDING IT TO
OTHER RURAL PARTS OF- THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND- AND REALLY I
GUESS PLANNING THE SEED. IN
POPULATIONS AND REGIONS OF THE
STATE WHERE THE THOUGHT PROCESS
IS WHAT WILL MAYBE WE CAN MOVE
IN THE DIRECTION OF OWNING A
ELECTRIC VEHICLE WENT WHEN IT'S
AFFORDABLE AND WHEN THE
POTENTIAL COST OF. ELECTRICITY
YOU KNOW- WE ISN'T- THE MAJOR
THREAT OF INSTALLING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AT YOUR HOME MORE
WE SPOKE OF YOU KNOW IN CASE OF
OUR REGION MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
YOU KNOW DEVELOPMENTS WORK LARGE
PORTION OF FOLKS LIVE SOAP BJT
ATTENTION TO THE QUESTION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
PARTICULAR AS SPACE WITH YOU ALL
. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IDEA
. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE PANELISTS
TO OUR TO OUR HERE PRESENTING ON
ON A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
ASPECTS I JUST WANT TO BRING
INTO THE SPACE I'M LOOKING AT
THE- PRESENTATION- REGARDING A-
CLEANER FREIGHT AND GOODS
MOVEMENT SO I REPRESENT.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE
WHICH WILL SOON BE FIFTY TWO
FOLLOWING REDISTRICTING. WHICH
INCLUDES THE COMMUNITIES OF
NORTHEAST LA ANY SAUCE ANGELES.
OUT WE ARE AT THE HEART I THINK
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES RIGHT
OUTSIDE DOWNTOWN LA BUT WE ARE
SURROUNDED BY FREEWAYS. SO IN MY
COMMUNITY WE HAVE THE TO THE
FIVE THE TEN THE SIXTY THE ONE
TEN THE ONE A ONE THE SEVEN TEN.
FREEWAYS SIDE THE ONE THIRTY
FOUR- I'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON THE
WORK RELATED TO THE PORTS. WHEN
IT COMES TO TRUCKS- HEAVY
FREIGHT MOVING FROM THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH- AND MOVING THROUGH MY
COMMUNITY TO GET TO THE INLAND
EMPIRE. AND SO WE WERE VERY-
COMMITTED TO PASSING A BE SEVEN
NINE FOR THE CLIMATE JOBS IN
EQUITY ACT. WHICH IS THE FIRST
OF ITS KIND AND FINALLY ALIGNS
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE
BOARD TO COLLABORATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR TO AND SHARE
DATA AND INFORMATION. RELATED TO
US SOMETHING THAT WE OFTEN MISS
IN THESE CONVERSATIONS AND THOSE
THAT THE CONVERSATION AN
INCLUSION OF WORKERS. AND SO. I
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO FIND A WAY TO
REALLY ENSURE THAT THIS BILL
WORKS. SO THAT ALL OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SPOKEN ABOUT TODAY THAT.
CALIFORNIA IS PUTTING INTO
POCKETS FOR. A GREEN CLEAN
TRUCKS FOR- MAKING IT AFFORDABLE
TO WORKERS MOST OF WHOM ARE
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF WHO ARE
MISCLASSIFIED TRUCK DRIVERS. AND
SO THEREFORE THEY DON'T QUALIFY
OR DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO. THE
RESOURCES THAT WE ARE PUTTING AT
THE TABLE TO BE ABLE TO- CHANGE
EIGHTY- YOU KNOW A GAS DRIVEN
TRUCK INTO A MORE CLEANER
VEHICLE. AND SO I WONDER IF YOU
CAN EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW. THE JOB IN THE WORK FORCE
RELATED TO A CLEANER FREIGHT AND
GOODS MOVEMENT ACTUALLY PLAYS A
ROLE IN THE REDUCTION. OF
EMISSIONS AND ENSURING THAT WE
ARE DOING THE WORK NECESSARY IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
YES. UP THE BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AND WE
ARE PUTTING. MONEY INTO POTS
THAT ALLOW FOR THE TRANSITION TO
OCCUR. BUT THEN HOW DOES THE TO
THE TRANSITION. ACTUALLY OCCUR.
WHEN THE WORKERS THEMSELVES
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THESE FUNDS
AND THE COMPANIES OR
CORPORATIONS THAT EMPLOY THEM AS
CLASSIFY THEM AND THEN RAKE IN
THE PROFITS FOR. THOSE VEHICLES
. I YEAH I WILL WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT BILL
AND WE HAVE A AND M. THE
GOVERNOR DID APPROVE OUR BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL SO IT'S PENDING
BEFORE- THE LEGISLATURE IN TERMS
OF FINDING OUR- OUR WORK ON THAT
BILL AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO. HAVING THAT APPROVED
IN MOVING FORWARD TO
IMPLEMENTATION- AND- YOU KNOW
YOU RAISE A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE I MEAN SO MANY OF THE
GOODS MOVEMENT IS DONE BY.
INDIVIDUAL DRIVERS ARE VERY
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS- AND YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DID LAST- FALL WHEN WE ADOPTED
OUR- FUNDING PLAN. IS WE REALLY
ARE ORIENTING OUR AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS MORE TOWARDS THOSE
SMALLER- OPERATOR SO THAT THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO ACCESS
THOSE FUNDS AND TO HIM TO MAKE A
TRANSITION TO A CLEANER VEHICLE
AND SO THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE
WHERE WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
THINK ABOUT HOW BEST TO- TO
SUPPORT THAT TRANSMIT TRANSITION
FOR SMALLER OPERATORS AND- AND
WE CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES- TO PRIORITIZE
WORK IN THOSE- ALONG THIS
RECORDERS IN THIS PART
COMMUNITIES- HEY. DEALING WITH
YOU KNOW SO. PROVIDING LEGAL
SUPPORT FOR SOUTH COAST INDIRECT
SOURCE RULE- DEFENSE IN THE
COURTS- AND REALLY WORKING ON
STRATEGIES THAT WILL BENEFIT
THOSE COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU-
YES GARCIA UGH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I WOULD JUST SAY TO
YOUR COMMENT ON- OR YOUR
PRESENTATION ON A JUSTICE AND
FOR WORK AND FOR PEOPLE RIGHT I
THINK THIS IS WHERE THE
ALIGNMENT FALLS IN A LOT OF
THOSE MISCLASSIFIED OF SMALL
BUSINESS OPERATORS TRUCK
OPERATORS LIVE IN THESE VERY
COMMUNITIES AND SO I WANT TO
WORK I THINK WE'RE ALL FOCUSED
ON FIGURING OUT. CLIMATE JUSTICE
EQUITY NOT ONLY FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE WANT TO PROTECT BUT FOR
THE VERY WORKERS THAT ACTUALLY
LIVE AND WORK AND SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES IN THESE COMMUNITIES
AND SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S AN ALIGNMENT AND
CONNECTION IN TERMS OF- THE PORT
GOODS MOVEMENT FREIGHT-
OBVIOUSLY THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES IS THE BIGGEST ONE OF
THE BIGGEST IN. THE ENTIRE
NATION IF NOT THE WORLD AND IT
RUNS THROUGH OF OUR ENTIRE STATE
AND THE NATION AND SO I THINK
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY THERE
THAT WE HAVEN'T QUITE FLUSHED
OUT OF THAT CERTAINLY ALIGNS
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS AS WELL AS
THE IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORTING
LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT- AND
FAMILIES IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU THAT'S ALL. THANK YOU.
BUT I JUST BRIEFLY RESPOND AS
WELL YEAH THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS I THINK THAT THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AS SOMEONE
WHO'S WORKED ON SEVERAL
ITERATIONS OF THE TRUCK RULES AT
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND ON
THE PLAN TO TRY TO HELP CLEAN UP
SOME OF THE POLLUTION AROUND THE
PORT OF STOCKTON. THAT'S
DEFINITELY AN ADVANCEMENT THAT
WE THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
HOW DOES THIS ALIGN WITH WORKERS
SO JUST AGAIN TO WAYS THAT THEIR
AGENCIES OPERATE THAT WERE
LOOKING TO IMPROVE AT LEAST IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. IS
TRANSFORMING INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
FROM A FIRST COME FIRST SERVE
BASIS TO SOMETHING THAT IS MORE
EQUITY ORIENTED AND MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO THE INDEPENDENT
OWNER OPERATORS INSTEAD OF THE
VERY LARGE FLEETS THAT HAVE LOTS
OF PEOPLE THAT CAN FILL OUT THE
PAPERWORK FOR THEM- AND FRANKLY
TO MEET OUR CLEAN AIR AND
CLIMATE GOALS WE ALSO THINK THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE AND- ENDS TO
ANY INCENTIVE MONEY FOR NATURAL
GAS TRUCKS WE REALLY SHOULD BE
GOING. FULLY ELECTRIC WORK
WHEREVER POSSIBLE SO THOSE ARE
JUST A FEW OF THE MEASURES THAT
WERE LOOKING TO IMPLEMENT-
KEEPING WORKERS AND COMMUNITY
HEALTH IN MIND. AND CAN I JUST
ADD TO THAT I JUST KIND OF ONE I
JUST WANT TO LIFT UP SOME OF THE
REALLY IMPORTANT- PILOT PROGRAMS
THAT. THE STATE HAS FUNDED AND
THAT REALLY ARE HELPING US LEARN
ABOUT WAYS TO IMPROVE GOODS
MOVEMENT- WE HAVE. PROGRAMS
THAT. THAT THAT- LOOK AT. YOU
KNOW. MOVING GOODS FROM PORTS TO
THE INLAND WAREHOUSES. BOTH
USING ELECTRIC TRACKS AND THEN
ALSO USING FUEL CELL- HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS YOU KNOW BOTH ZERO
EMISSION. OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WILL REALLY- AT YOU KNOW ADDRESS
THAT THE IMPACTS. ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND MAKE THAT. GOODS
MOVEMENT SECTOR A CLEANER SECTOR
. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I THINK A-
I JUST HAVE. MAYBE TWO MORE
QUESTIONS AND- BUT WE WILL TRY
TO WRAP UP IF. WE SHOULD TAKE
YOUR TIME I JUST WANTED TO- THAT
CHAIR RANDOLPH I JUST WANTED TO-
REITERATE- APPOINT THE VICE
CHAIR BACKER MADE- ACCORDING TO
THE R. LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- IN ORDER TO MEET OUR- SB
THIRTY TWO GOAL OF REDUCING. OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY 40%
BY TWENTY THIRTY THE ESTIMATED
THAT WE NEED TO REDUCE. OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY 4% A
YEAR. AND YET YOU KNOW EVEN WITH
THE PANDEMIC SLOWDOWN- IT'S I
KNOW YOU INDICATED EARLIER THAT-
THAT- THAT- WE ONLY HAVE
ESTIMATED- EMISSIONS DATA AT
THIS POINT BUT- IT IT APPEARS
THAT WE'RE- IN THE RANGE OF A-
2% REDUCTION. FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN SO THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
NOT ONLY YOU KNOW A PANDEMIC. A
SLOWDOWN BUT IT'S 202-020-2120
TWENTY TWO- A 2% REDUCTION BELOW
THE TWENTY NINETEEN LEVELS. SO
IT IT IT YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN
THE DATA SEEMS TO SUGGEST. THAT
CLEARLY WERE NOT ON A TRAJECTORY
TO MEET OUR TWENTY. THIRTY SB
THIRTY TWO GOAL- I KNOW YOU
INDICATED EARLIER THAT- THAT
DATE IS STILL PRELIMINARY BUT
ARE YOU ARE YOU ARE. CAN YOU
GIVE US A PREVIEW OF SUMMER
RECKLESS TURNAROUND IN TERMS OF
THE TRAJECTORY OF- OF BECAUSE IT
IT APPEARS THEY WERE WE CLEARLY
ARE NOT ON TRACK TO MEET- A
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL. WELL I WOULD
SAY THAT THE THAT THE JURY STILL
OUT ON THAT BECAUSE WE
DO AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WE DO
HAVE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
INCREASED IN STRINGENCY STARTING
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE EVERYTHING
FROM CAP AND TRADE INCREASES
STRINGENCY RENEWABLES PORTFOLIO
STANDARD INCREASE IN STRINGENCY.
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD. RATE
SO LIKE THE EVENING YOU KNOW WE
NEED TIME TO SEE HOW THAT'S
WORKING THROUGH THE SYSTEM AND
WHAT EFFECT THAT WILL BE AND
THAT'S WHY WE LOOK AT THE
INVENTORY. NUMBERS YOU KNOW THE
ACTUAL INVENTORY NUMBERS EVERY
YEAR- AND SO THAT'S WHAT REALLY
WILL TELL US KIND F. YOU KNOW
HOW WE'RE DOING AND WHERE WE'RE
GOING. OKAY AND MY LAST QUESTION
AT THIS POINT IS- THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I IMAC REPORT-
RECOMMENDED- THAT THE UPCOMING
SCOPING PLAN- MODEL OR PROVIDE
BASELINE EMISSIONS SCENARIO- A%
BASELINE EMISSION SCENARIO THAT
MODELS THE EFFECT OF NON CAP AND
TRADE POLICIES SO THAT TO. YOU
KNOW IF THAT WOULD INFORM WHAT-
WHAT THE STATE NEEDS TO- IN
TERMS OF ADDITIONAL ACTIONS TO
DO TO ACHIEVE THESE. AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS THAT WE HAVE SAID
WILL BE UPCOMING- SCOPING PLAN
INCLUDE A SUCH A- BASELINE
EMISSION SCENARIO. WE DO WE WILL
IN THE AM IN THE DRAFT PROVIDED
A BUSINESS AS USUAL SCENARIO AND
THEN WE WILL BEMOVING ON FROM
THERE IN TERMS OF IDENTIFYING
THE PROGRAMS AND THEIR
PRODUCTIONS WE EXPECT TO SEE SO
THEY'LL BE A LOT OF ROBUST
ANALYSIS IN THE DRAFT THAT WILL
BE COMING OUT. OKAY SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS WHEN WILL WE KNOW
THE INVENTORIES YOU SEE IT'S
KIND OF AT THE ESTIMATED BATES
JUST WIPED CLEAR. OH GOSH IS
THERE'S A WHOLE I MEAN BASICALLY
WE GET A BUNCH OF REPORTED
INFORMATION- AND THERE'S ALWAYS
A LAG YOU KNOW WE GET THE
REPORTED INFORMATION AND THEN WE
RECEIVE IT AND THEN YOU KNOW WE
KIND OF. PUT IT TOGETHER AND IN
THE INVENTORY NUMBERS AND THEN
WE RELEASE IT AND THERE'S A
SPECIFIC TIMELINE- AND I DO NOT
KNOW THAT I'VE TAUGHT MY HEAD I
AM HAPPY TO HAVE STAFF GET THAT
TWO YEAR. OKAY GREAT. WE'LL GET
WELL JUST A MINUTE AGAIN THANK
THE CHAIR- FOR THIS THIS HEARING
AGES TO ECHO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS ON CAP AND TRADE AND WE
DISCUSSES WELL AND I THINK. WE
SHOULD THE CONSTRUCTIVE-
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE. MADE
HERE TODAY AND ALSO TO SAY WE'RE
GONNA. ECHO MY COLLEAGUES I
THINK IT'S UP TO US TO. MAKE
SURE THAT. WE DO THIS BRING
EVERYONE ALONG. AND WHETHER
THAT'S INFRASTRUCTURE MULTI
FAMILY WITH AN- INTRODUCTION
WELCOME NEIGHBORHOODS OF OTHER
WORK WORK LOOKING AT A LOT OF
THAT THIS YEAR THIS CLIMATE
EQUITY TRUST- THAT WAS JUST
INTRODUCED. TO TAKE. UP THINGS
LIKE WILDFIRE OUT OF RATES. AND
PUT IT SOMEWHERE ELSE SO WE'RE
NOT YEARS WE DECREASE
ELECTRICITY RATES WE CAN. WHICH
IS VERY REGRESSIVE TAX AND WE
CAN INCREASE. IN THE INCREASE
DECARBONISATION MORE QUICKLY.
ALL THINGS YOU KNOW THAT WERE
WORKING ON OF THIS YEAR- AND-
I'M WILL BE IMPORTANT PARTS WORK
ALSO THANK YOU. THE YOU. ANY
OTHER CALL OUR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THING NINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR TIME
IN YOUR TESTIMONY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT- THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED
IF IF I NEED TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS VERGE WELSH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CARBON CAPTURE
COALITION- WERE- BUSINESS LABOR
COALITION COMMITTED TO ENSURING
THAT- CCS TECHNOLOGIES CAN BE
OF- KEY PART OF OUR EFFORTS TO
REACH OUR COMMON GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA- AND GREAT
CONVERSATION VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE- THE FOCUS ON
BOTH THE SCOPING PLAN IN MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE- ANALYSIS
IS THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY PLANNING
ON. HAVING A MORE FOCUSED
DISCUSSION AROUND THE TOPIC SO
WE'LL DEFINITELY LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT AS WELL- BUT I DID JUST
WANT TO SAY- TODAY- THE REALITY
IS WHAT WE ARE NOT GOING TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT CCS
TECHNOLOGY AND THAT IS YOU KNOW
THAT IS NOT A THE CONCLUSION
THAT- THE- THE AIRBOARD REACHED
IN A VACUUM. OF COURSE- AS I'M
SURE ALL OF YOU ARE WELL AWARE-
THAT'S THE CONCLUSION OF
VIRTUALLY EVERY CREDIBLE EXPERT
ANALYSIS THE I. P. C. THE I. A.
CALIFORNIA FOCUSED ANALYSIS FROM
STANFORD AND MARK LIVERMORE
AMONG OTHERS WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE THESE TECHNOLOGIES.
TO ACHIEVE OUR CARBON GOALS AND
SO- WHAT WE NEED IN THIS STATE
IS. TO HAVE LIKE WE DO WITH
OTHER APPROACHES TO REDUCE
POLLUTION OR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS A POLICY FRAMEWORK
THAT'S GOING TO SUPPORT THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES
ON A SCALE AND A PACE THAT'S
ACTUALLY GONNA ENABLE THEM TO BE
KEY CONTRIBUTORS TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS- IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
AS YOU ALLUDED TO MISTER CHAIR
THERE THERE IS A ROBUST
CONVERSATION- THAT IS GOING ON
IT WILL CERTAINLY CONTINUE I AM
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUS
ON ON THIS IS THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL- BUT I DID JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT POINT- FOR YOU-
THAT THE MATH AND THE SCIENCE
ARE CLEAR HERE THAT C. C. U. S.
IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE PART. OF
OUR APPROACH SO THANKS VERY MUCH
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION WITH YOU ALL.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING- YOU CAN
HEAR ME. SELECT A CAITLYN REDNER
CENTER- WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND- I ALSO SIT ON THE
MAC AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT
TODAY BUT BUT I'M HERE SOLELY AS
ETF AT THE MOMENT- I'M REALLY
PLEASED TO HEAR FROM CHAIR
RANDALL TODAY THAT CARB IS
PLANNING TO- ESTIMATE THE ROLE
OF CAP AND TRADE IN THE DRAFT
SCOPING PLAN- I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND. THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ALL OF OUR
EXISTING CLIMATE POLICIES AS WE
CHART A PATH TO TWENTY THIRTY
AND BEYOND- SO THAT'S THAT'S
EXCITING TO HEAR AND I WOULD ADD
THAT. YOU KNOW REGARDLESS OF THE
RELATIVE CONTRIBUTION OF CAP AND
TRADE WHATEVER THAT MAGIC
PERCENTAGE NUMBER TURNS OUT TO
BE IT'S REALLY ESSENTIAL THAT
THE EMISSIONS CAP. BE REMAIN
DESIGNED AS AN EMISSIONS
BACKSTOPS- YOU KNOW THIS WAS SET
OUT IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SCOPING PLAN AND IT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE I MEAN AS WAS DISCUSSED
HERE TODAY THERE ARE INHERENT
UNCERTAINTIES WITH MODELING AND
MODELING ASSUMPTIONS AND
PLANNING DOCUMENTS AND THAT THAT
JUST SORT OF COMES WITH THE
TERRITORY. AND WE NEED TO
MINIMIZE THOSE BUT IF WE HAVE A
WELL DESIGNED EMISSIONS CAP WE
HAVE A CREDIBLE BACKSTOPS THEY
CAN PROVIDE THE GREATEST
POSSIBLE CERTAINTY OF MEETING
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOALS- SO TO THAT END. I WOULD
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD- TO UNDERTAKE A
RULEMAKING AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE. FOR
CHANGES TO TAKE EFFECT IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AND TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROGRAM'S AMBITION REFLECTS
OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND IS
DESIGNED TO BE THAT BACKSTOPS
WHO WE ARE ON TRACK TO MEET-
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL. AND AS CHAIR
RANDALL SAID YOU KNOW MEETING AN
IMPORTANT MILESTONE TO ACHIEVE
NET ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONSAFTER THAT- I MEAN
THIS OBVIOUSLY NEEDS TO BE AN
OPEN AND DELIBERATIVE RULEMAKING
PROCESS- AND AS PART OF THAT
PROCESS WE WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE CARD TO LOOK AT ALL OF
THE- AYE YOU MAC N. E. JACK
RECOMMENDATIONS- YOU KNOW WE
HEARD ABOUT AN EMISSIONS
CONTAINMENT RESERVE TODAY. YOU
KNOW POSSIBLE ADJUSTMENTS TO
FREE ALLOCATION TO INDUSTRY- AND
THERE'S OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS IN
BOTH OF THOSE REPORTS THAT. YOU
KNOW SHOULD REALLY BE CONSIDERED
IN AN IN AN OPEN AND DELIVERED A
PROCESS THAT CARD- BUT AGAIN TO
BEGIN AS SOON AS POSSIBLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO YOU KNOW
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND BE WELL
POSITIONED TO HIT OUR TWENTY
THIRTY GOAL. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE AUDIENCE SEEING NONE DO WE
OPERATED TO HAVE ANYONE- ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE PHONE.
YOU FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN THEY OFFER
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS NIKHIL KUMAR ALONG WITH
THE GOLF GROUP HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNTS ARAMBULA-
A CARBON NEUTRALITY IS IMPORTANT
FOR STUDENTS ON MY LAND MAJOR
ISSUES FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THEIR I'M- VERY. IMPORTANT OUT
THAT WE DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
THE INPUT ASSUMPTIONS LIKE
TECHNOLOGY UPDATE EARLIER COULD
NOT INFORMATION TO THE. THE
INITIAL RESULTS OF STOPPING I AM
CALLING. USUALLY THE LAW THAT OF
THE USED OR NOT OPTIMISTIC
MODELS. THE INTERNATIONAL
RESULTAR VICIOUS AT BEST DO NOT
PAINT A COMPLETE PICTURE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE ADDITIONAL
DISCLOSURE OF THE TECHNICAL
DOCUMENTS IN MAY. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ANALYZE THE
SCENARIOS AMAL RESULTS WHAT DO
YOU THINK THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHER LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES.
WHAT ARE COMMON THREE YEARS
SINCE THE BOARD ON THE SKIPPING
PLAN OF THE COUNTRY'S. AGAIN
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT TO NOTE THAT
**** AFFORDABILITY CONSUMER
ADOPTION JOB IMPACT MY WHOLE BE
CONSIDERED. IN THE FORTHCOMING.
MODELING- FORTY KEY FALL COOL
WITH ON THE TABLE IS WE LOOK TO.
ARTICLE WE'RE CURRENTLY LIVE-
HISTORY WITH- WAR AND OTHER.
EVENTUALLY CREATING BUT THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
UNPREDICTABILITY AND HOW THE
FUTURE WILL WILL PRESENT ITSELF
CONTRIBUTIONS WILL NOT BE FOR
THE NATION TO TRIGGER AND GO ON
TO THAT POINT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KEEP THE FLEXIBILITY IN MARKETS
LIKE THE WILL COMPEL STANDARD.
AND THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
FINALLY I WANT TO- MAKE THE
STATEMENTS WITH REGARD TO SOME
OF THE THINGS TO SAY- WE CANNOT
INFER TRENDS FROM PRELIMINARY
DATA FROM UNVERIFIED EMISSIONS
REPORTING- WE OPPOSED. THE
INCLUSION OF THE INITIAL
ACCORDING. BERMAN AND BUDGET
TRAILER BILL A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WE PREDICTED THAT IT WOULD LEAD
TO THE SPREAD OF THIS NOT SO
COMPASSIONATE CONTRACT INCORRECT
INCLUSIONS THAT WE'RE SEEING
TODAY. WE WANT TO REMIND THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO THAT THE CORE
POLICIES REMOVED VARY FROM CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM AND SO
CONTINUED INTRODUCTION AND
PURSUE THE OF THESE ONE OFF TYPE
POLICIES WILL REMAIN VALUE FROM
THE PROGRAM AND US REDUCE OUR
ABILITY TO INCENTIVIZE THANK
FUTURE AT. STATEN WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AS WE
GET TO DIVE INTO THIS COMPANY
PLAN MARK AND THANK YOU. FOR THE
OPTION YOU UNLOCK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S A GOOD LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HARDY IS THAT
ME AND MY IN THE- CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES COMMITTEE THAT IS. AND
A- GREAT- WELL I'M A LITTLE BIT
OF A NEWBIE TO THE LEGISLATURE
BUT I'VE BEEN LISTENING TO
HEARINGS. AND JUST HAVE A COUPLE
OF GENERAL COMMENTS OF SEEMS TO
TIE INTO- THE LIKE LITHIUM
MINING. HEARING THAT I WATCHED
AWHILE BACK- AND ALTHOUGH LIKE
LITHIUM MINING THAT IS
APPARENTLY SLATED TO BE
HAPPENING DOWN BY THE SOLVENCY
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN AND THIS
SORT OF BROADER. AGENDA IF YOU
WILL OF ALL THE ZERO EMISSIONS
STUFF- I GUESS I'M A LITTLE
PERPLEXED BY IT JUST BECAUSE I'M
KIND OF COMING FROM A STANDPOINT
OF- BEING A SMALL SCALE FARMER
AND IT'S JUST INTERESTING FOR ME
TO HEAR ABOUT THIS KIND OF STUFF
YOU KNOW THE HYDROGEN. NOT NONE
OF THIS STUFF IS ACTUALLY ZERO
EMISSIONS WHEN YOU START TO DIG
INTO IT AND SO. THIS FOR ME WAS
A LITTLE BIT OF A STRANGE
HEARING BECAUSE IT RATHER RAM
LIKE AN INFOMERCIAL FOR
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T REALLY
REFLECT THE REALITY OF SOME OF
WHAT I WAS CALIFORNIANS ARE
DEALING WITH AGAIN OF THE SMALL
SCALE FARMER- IT WAS REALLY
STRANGE FOR ME TO HEAR. THIS
NOTION THAT SOMEHOW THE TRUCKERS
YOU KNOW WHO YOU FIRED
INCIDENTLY BECAUSE THEY WON'T
TAKE THE SHOT AND THE SAME WITH
THE BACKUP OF THE PORT WORKERS
IN LONG BEACH AND LA CONFIG
WON'T TAKE THE SHOT. ARE SOMEHOW
MAGICALLY JUST GONNA BE LIKE
DRIVING AROUND IN LIKE ELECTRIC
SEMIS ALL THE SUDDEN THIS
HEARING JUST SEEMED REALLY- VERY
LIKE PIE IN THE SKY TO ME AGAIN
OF SOMEONE WHO'S LIVING ON THE
GROUND IN CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
THEY- CAN GO AND THEIR MANAGERS
ALL AROUND. FOR THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE SEVENTY THREE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE CLICK. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MURATSUCHI AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. IT'S GREAT TO
HEAR THE SERIOUS AND THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC TODAY. MY NAME
IS JOHN BLUE AND I'M CALLING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL EMISSIONS TRADING
ASSOCIATION OR I NEED TO. I
NEEDED THE NONPROFIT BUSINESS
ORGANIZATION CREATED TO
ESTABLISH FUNCTIONAL
INTERNATIONAL FRAMEWORK FOR
TRADING IN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. WE SUPPORT EMISSIONS
TRADING THE RESULT IN A REAL AND
VERIFIABLE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTIONS WHILE
BALANCING ECONOMIC EFFICIENCY
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
INTEGRITY. AND SOCIAL EQUITY.
THE DOCTOR BIRCH ARE INDICATED
IS REMARKS MARKETS DON'T WORK
WELL WITH REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY
. QUERY ABOUT THE LIFE OF THE
PROGRAM BEYOND TWENTY THIRTY
WHAT DO A GREAT DEAL TO ADDRESS
UNSERVED AND REMOVE SOME OF THE
WORRY ABOUT BANK ALLOWANCE. AND
WE WOULD ESPECIALLY WELCOME
CLARIFICATION ON CARDS VIEW ON
THE ROLE FOR CAP AND TRADE
BEYOND TWENTY THIRTY DURING THE
SCOPING PLAN PROCESS. I BELIEVE
THE CAR ALREADY HAS THE
REGULATORY AUTHORITY TO USE CAP
AND TRADE AS A LEADING POLICY
FOR ACHIEVING CARBON NEUTRALITY
. WE'RE CONCERNED WITH THE PUSH
TO USE TOO MANY COMPLEMENTARY
POLICIES AND TOP DOWN COMMAND
AND CONTROL REGULATIONS TO
ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY FOR
MANY REASONS. INCLUDING THAT
THEY'RE OFTEN INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE. FOR EXAMPLE A RECENT
ALEJO REPORT CALCULATES THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF CARBS LOCAL
SOURCE PROGRAM FOR FROM THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO OVER EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER TON OF
CARBON REDUCED THANK YOU YOUR
MARIO WHAT IN YOUR RECORD
PROGRAM. LAST COMMENT OKAY AS
OTHERS HAVE NOTED. YEAH
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY A TINY
PORTION OF THE OVERALL GLOBAL
EMISSIONS OUR GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY IS LEAD BY EXAMPLE
AND MORE COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH
IS MORE REPLICABLE BY OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THANK YOU IF WE
ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY IN
EXPENSE. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YOU
WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND FROM
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RELAXED. AND
I RIVER THAT YOU TO BRADLEY FOR
U. S. SENATE. AND I'M CALLING
BECAUSE- ALTHOUGH I APPRECIATE
INNOVATION IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWYERS OUT THERE THE WARRIORS
TRYING TO WORK BETTER TRYING TO
REDUCE HARMFUL EMISSIONS INTO
THE ATMOSPHERE. BY REDUCING OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT DEGREE DAY ALL
OF THE STORE COUNTY. THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE
IN CARDIFF. AS WITH THE WAS
DESCRIBED. ROBERT RIVAS SPEAKER
AND AS USUAL THIS OUT. I
HAPPENED TO NOTICE THAT WITH THE
GREEN NEW DEAL IT WILL
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE VERY.
INDEPENDENT BUT ARE
DISADVANTAGED. SO ARE. THE
PEOPLE THAT WILL HAVE PRIVILEGED
POSITIONS ONLY BE ABLE TO AFFORD
THAT WHILE THE REST OF US WILL
HAVE TO WRITE A BOOK. REALLY THE. OUR GOAL FAIR TO YOU ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND SHOULD BE BE
THE FOCUS ON BEING FAIR AND
HAVING ACCORDING ACCORDING AT
THE AFFABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
SO I THINK YOU GUYS SHOULD NOT
THE CARD. OTHER SOURCES OF
ENERGY RIGHT NOW ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE'RE COMING OUT OF A PANDEMIC
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THINK BEFORE
YOU BEFORE YOU DO NOT TRY TO
FINISH BEFORE YOU DO THAT I
THINK YOU GUYS NEED TO. WORK ON
. OUR INNOVATION AND- AND- YOU
KNOW WHAT ALL THE BIG MONEY
DONATIONS AND I HAD MORE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS. INSTEAD
OF TAKING IT AWAY FROM ON
CALIFORNIA OPTIONS. FONG VERY
MUCH FOR. LISTENING THANK YOU A
NICE COLOR PLEASE THANK YOU WILL
. THIRTY WILL GO TO THE LINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS HOWEVER HE- CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. THANK YOU I'M-
AND I'M WITH THREE KIDS ARE I'M
A NUMBER THREE FIFTY BAY AREA-
THANK YOU CHAIR MURATSUCHI AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING- I WANT TO
SAY THAT I AM A PERSON WHO TAKES
THE BUS BY CHOICE AND WALK AND
BIKE. BECAUSE I HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DO THAT I WOULD INCREASE
RIGHT CAN DO THAT AND THERE IS
NO ECONOMY WITHOUT LIGHT. AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS FOR KIDS WITH ASTHMA AND
CANCER TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LIVED IN- ESPECIALLY. IN A
IN. LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR NEAR HIGHWAYS. NEAR POWER
PLANTS EXCEPTIONAL- ARE HARM TO
GREET ME THE MORE. WE WASTE. THE
MORE WE USE FOSSIL FUELS. THE
MORE WE GO FOR ALL SOLUTION SUCH
AS BIO FUELS. AND CARBON CAPTURE
WHICH CARBON CAPTURE MAY
EVENTUALLY HELP. SOME BUT IT IS
NOT A WAY TO GET. OUR LIVES BACK
ON TRACK IN THE CURRENT CLIMATE
CRISIS. I WANT TO- BRING IN MY
COMMENTS FIRST. I THINK THAT THE
FACT THAT CARBON THANK YOU
UNIPRO CAN YOU WRAP UP STATEMENT
DIPLOMATIC AND PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH- YOU SHOULD REALLY
CONSIDER. THE THANK ARM WHERE
IT'S HAPPENING FONG FOR INSTANCE
THE BIOFUEL REFINERIES GOING IN
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT'S
COLOR PLACE. THIRTY NINE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CAN HEAR ME YES. THE DOT MICHAEL
CARROLL D. A. R. R. O. L. L.
WITH LIEBERMAN WALKED INTO NOT
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR CLIMATE
AMBITION WHICH IS AN INFORMAL
COALITION CAPTURED STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING BUT REGULATED ENTITIES
AND FINANCIAL INVESTORS. MY
COMMENTS ARE DIRECTED CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM I'D LIKE TO
CONCEPTION TO ACCOMPLISHMENT BUT
ONE OF THE SPEAKERS AT THE
CAPITAL PROGRAM INCREASES LOCAL
AIR POLLUTION BY DESIGN WHICH
DID POINT OUT THAT THAT WAS
CONTRARY TO FINDINGS THE
RECENTLY RELEASED A WE HEART
STUDY WHICH FOUND GREAT. THIS
YEAR IT REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM
FACILITIES THAT THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM BUT THE COLOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES DELTA
CONTRADICTS THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE GOT IT BY
THE UC SANTA BARBARA STUDY ON
THIS TOPIC. FINALLY DOLLARS
BILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT TO
DISPATCH COMMUNITIES THE
CALIFORNIA ABOUT THE BOND WHICH
IS FUNDED SOLELY. WITH CAP AND
TRADE PROCEEDS. THESE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO I REPORT THAT BUT
FIVE PROJECTS FUND WITH TWO
POINT ONE BILL DOLLARS IN
CAPITAL GROSS BETWEEN TWENTY
ONE. TO ONE BILLION WHICH WAS TO
DISPATCH. WITHIN THESE OF THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM OTHERS
COUNTRY HE JUDGES DOUBLE CAP
COULD BE REDUCED RECOMMENDED
MORE ROBUST PROGRAM. MANAGER AT
LEAST TWENTY FORTY FIVE
RESPONSIBLE FOR KEEPING 50% OF
THE REQUIRED EMISSIONS ABATEMENT
BETWEEN TWENTY TO. TWENTY FORTY
FIVE THE IMPLEMENTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. S. COLOR PLACE. HE
WILL CUT THE LINE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO IS THAT ME YES YOU. YOU KNOW I JUST WANTED OF A OF
A KIND OF OBSERVATION- IF YOU
CHANGE TO ME THAT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LEAVE AND THEY DON'T
LISTEN TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
BECAUSE THE LAST TIME I CHECKED
GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY ABOUT
PEOPLE AND IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
LAWMAKERS SO. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THAT SORT OF OBSERVATION
BECAUSE I THINK IN THE FUTURE IT
WILL PROBABLY BE- BENEFICIAL TO
ACTUALLY. HOW THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON COMMITTEE'S. DAY AND LISTEN
TO WHAT THE PUBLIC HAS TO SAY
BECAUSE- THE PUBLIC ACTUALLY.
PAYS YOUR SALARY. AND YOU KNOW
WE'LL LET YOU AND WORK KIND OF
NOTICING- SOME INCONSISTENCIES
DOWN THERE LIKE WE'RE BEING KEPT
OUT OF HEARINGS AND- PEOPLE
DON'T SHOW UP TO YOUR COUNTRY'S
OF BEEN THERE NOT LIKE. AND
THANK YOU THE LION EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SORRY WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- ROB
SPIEGEL SENIOR POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION BTA.
I WANTED TO SAY THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE. YOU GREAT COMMENTS IN
RESPONSE TO TODAY'S HEARING. OR
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF
CMCSA HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN EVERY WORKSHOPS
CONDUCTED BY KARBI LEADING TO
THE SCHOOL BIG BAND UPDATE. AND
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO SHARE OUR
COALITION COMMENTS AND CONCERNS
FOR THE BROADER INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE ATTENTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AN UNDERSTANDING
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF. THE RECENT
SCOPING PLAN NOW BROADLY
SPEAKING THAT. CALIFORNIA MUST
INNOVATE IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY. PART OF THAT
INNOVATION IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW TECHNOLOGIES THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION AND USE A
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE THE UTILIZED
EVERY AVAILABLE TOOL. IN THE
TOOLBOX TO ACHIEVE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS MINIMIZE COSTS AND
CARBON EMISSION LEAKAGE. STATUTE
ALSO MANDATES THAT THESE
CONSIDERATIONS ARE ALL THE
PEOPLE AT THE GAPS. SO SEVERAL
OF THE SCOPING PLAN ALTERNATIVES
ARE NOT FEASIBLE THESE ARE THE
ALTERNATE CENTER MAXIMIZING COST
AT ALL SO EMISSIONS LEAKAGE. AND
SHUTTING DOWN ENTIRE SECTORS OF
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY SHOULD BE
CONCERNING SINCE THESE ARE THE
INDUSTRY'S THE EDITORS OF THE
INVESTOR CAN ALREADY BE. THAT
UNDER GIRD CALIFORNIA'S NEEDED
EXPANSION FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ELECTRICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THE FUTURE CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
THANK YOU ARAMBULA THAT'D BE
WOULD BE PAPERWORK AT THIS
COMMITTEE. AND THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
COMMON THANKS SIR THANK YOU.
THAT'S HELPED. HE SAID YOUR
CHAIR WE HAVE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THE PLAN THANK YOU VERY- THIS
MAY IS ADJOURNED.